the officers
out of elizabeth city north carolina who
are involved in the shooting of andrew
brown will not
be charged it has been ruled that the
shooting was justified so of course
this is not working out for black lives
matter protesters they're already
protesting in the city
still light out so we'll see what ends
up happening
i don't want to say there will be riots
so it's just right now protests
but i think look there's going to be a
weekend and usually on the weekends when
things get really
raucous so we'll see but there's a
couple other stories that i really
want to get into in this context too
there's one story out of
i think it's arkansas where a man just
stopped a mass shooting with a rifle
and you're not going to hear a lot about
it because it was stopped
it was stopped because a guy was armed
so you know we hear our big fan second
amendment so we'll talk about that
and we've got a big story out of philly
a d.a who is backed by soros so that's
that's that's true right yeah
yeah ryan's telling us yes backed by
soros might actually get crushed
so this is going to be interesting all
these these different uh issues coming
together
and then uh obama saying you know ufos
are real so i guess we'll talk about
that because
you know everyone trusts obama uh yeah
well joining us today is writer
ryan james gardeski thanks for having me
on do you want to give a brief
introduction of
what you do uh i am a political
consultant and writer i wrote a book
called they're not listening how the
elites created the national populist
revolution about national populism i
write about this a lot i have a
uh substance newsletter called uh the
national populist newsletter
every week uh i come out with all the
news for national populist candidates
political parties opinion uh
politicians and are you a national
population i branded it so yeah i guess
so but i better do this
newsletter every week and basically all
the news from all around the world with
these people and then i do deep dives
into elections and and
issues and demographics and then i do an
essay so you subscribe to the newsletter
on substance or
get the book and i do camp campaigns for
my bread and butter so
wow yeah and crossland over here for me
and crossland.net did you say that the
the that the elites basically created
national popularity yeah so like my
whole
philosophy is like one of the books so
basically you know everyone who hated
trump
made him everyone from like the bushes
to the clintons
all their policies from immigration to
trade to war
they they you know if you look at
polling about immigration
for 50 years americans wanted less
immigration they got more of it
they didn't want to sit there and go
into iraq they didn't want to sit there
and stay in afghanistan
and they were just and and you know h.w
bush ran
saying i'm not going to do what reagan
did i'm going to break down military and
not be involved in the world
he was defeated by clinton who said the
same thing who was defeated but who was
replaced then by bush who promised a
humble foreign policy was replaced by
obama who promised a peaceful foreign
policy
and it was 25 years of americans voting
for the guy who said i'm not going to be
involved in wars anymore
and they got more wars issues like that
immigration
the degeneration of the west opening to
china
all those people who sat there and said
no this is going to be what's going to
be
mass prosperity and you're going to love
it you know middle america
and they got screwed over and decades
before
decades before you know it happened with
trump we orban came to power in hungary
we had the
uh den uh parties in denmark parties in
south america parties in africa all
these political parties were happening
across the entire world
and they were going unnoticed when
brexit and trump happen they're like wow
this is incred
where where did this come out from no
it's been happening everywhere
you just ignored it and that's how the
elites created
and created it by the way across the
entire globe right on we'll get in all
that stuff
whoa yeah yeah yeah so i'm also in the
corner i'm really looking forward to
this conversation
it's gonna be fun and funny and we'll
learn a lot before we get started head
over to timcast.com and click the
members only button to become a member
and you will get access to the members
only area where we will have an
exclusive segment coming up after the
show just for all of you special members
we've set this up
in the event that we get banned but more
importantly because we want to grow and
expand produce more content so of course
we have a new show we have the vlog
which is uh we're only into our fifth
episode but the goal is to eventually
get a daily vlog set up you can find
that on the website as well
and then as you know we've talked about
the paranormal podcast we're gonna do a
bunch of other shows
we're actually in the process of setting
up a sitcom a whole bunch of really
awesome stuff over at timcast.com so
sign up but don't forget to like
share subscribe hit the notification
bell really uh copy that url to this
page post it on your facebook or twitter
it's the most powerful thing you can do
to help get the word out
and help you know just have people learn
about what's going on maybe outside of
their bubble
and if you're listening on itunes or
spotify give us a good review let's talk
about this
first story and i gotta tell you my
friends boy am i just
over all of this but i think it's
important news
so sometimes the news can be boring i'm
not so much so sure that this is boring
i think it's going to heat up a lot of
people getting really angry but i'm just
i don't know how many times i can hear a
story about you know cop involved
shooting black lives matter is angry
demanding reform
even after black lives matter has
actually won on all of these different
cases they just keep
going they don't stop there's no there's
no end in sight
so here's the story from abc news they
say no charges for deputies in andrew
brown junior shooting
district attorney said the officers were
justified in using deadly force
according to the d.a
elizabeth city north carolina d.a andrew
wumble womble
said at a news conference tuesday
morning the three deputies who opened
fire on brown a father of seven
were justified in their use of deadly
force because brown drove his vehicle
toward them
and allegedly made contact with one
deputy twice before officers fired their
weapons
womble said he made his decision based
on the results of an investigation
by the north carolina state bureau of
investigation quote mr brown's death
while tragic was justified
because mr brown's actions caused three
deputies with the posca tank county
sheriff's office
to reasonably believe it was necessary
to use deadly force to protect
themselves and
others attorneys for brown's family
released a statement tuesday afternoon
calling wamble's decision
an attempt to whitewash this unjustified
killing
and requested the us department of
justice intervene immediately
i don't know how much one about that
they will intervene immediately uh
you know if it was seen if it i mean he
was fleeing from the scene of a crime
right
and there is and you can clearly see in
the video the cop jumping out of the way
yeah because we're not jumping but he's
like
he was looking like he was going to run
over the cop yeah i don't know if the
department of justice i mean i don't
know you never know what this with this
department of justice but i don't know
if
they're gonna sit there and say this is
the case we're gonna you know fall on
the blade for
it was like that cop who shot that 13
year old 14 year old black girl who was
wielding a knife about to stab another
one sit there and say no this is
you know she hadn't you know she was in
i guess foster care and her mother's
like
she was a perfect child i'm like you
didn't even have custody of her i don't
know what you're talking about but she
was wielding a knife at the time
when you're in the process of committing
a crime and you're stopped in the
committed crime it's really hard to sit
there and justify it it's not
everything is not george floyd in this
in this case out of elizabeth city we've
already got people
protesting at least i'm pretty sure this
is the these are the photos protests
coming out of elizabeth city uh
north carolina and i've heard already
some of the audio
and people are chanting hands up don't
shoot
which is a lie it's
a lie it's a lie
it's just it's it's a lot like brown did
not and he never said that and it was
people like
um who's the woman from the view uh
sunny hostin no sonny hostin
who was on cnn who perpetuated that lie
and it's
it's it's its own its own myth right now
yeah that's like
it is bizarre how this like is
continuing but we we bring the facts
here on tim cast irl so i
pulled up everyone's favorite source
wikipedia
which says the united states department
of justice investigation found the hands
up claim was
inconsistent with the physical and
forensic evidence and the witness
testimony surrounding the brown shooting
they are still chanting hands up don't
shoot
that's why i'm like i am kind of over
this but what do you do
when they are not and they want to throw
a brick through your window or burn down
your it's a mob
it's a mob mentality and you can't
reason with the mob mentality
you can't you can't say that facts will
never ever
perpetuate that and you just have to sit
there i mean let them protest let them
chant whatever but if they get violent
you just have to completely squash it
like you can't allow this to fester but
here here's the other issue too because
you know
we talked about this the other day with
like gun control i'm sure we'll get into
it again
when a bunch of people believe a bunch
of fake bs
yeah and they're believing it because of
protests and i'm totally i'm not
disparaging the protest i'm just saying
there is a spread of misinformation that
results in laws which just make
everything worse
notably in brooklyn center minneapolis
i'm sorry minnesota just north of
minneapolis basically a part of
minneapolis
they're now gonna have unarmed civilian
traffic stops oh it's gonna be wonderful
it's gonna be great right it's like
that's defunding police so now you got a
bunch of
untrained rookies running around as if
that will make things better
then it gets worse and they say see look
this proves it's like no you
it's like someone like breaking
something and then like complaining
about it not working but because you sit
there
and we have been trained basically
society if you have an emotional if
you're
emotionally disturbed by something it's
really you're in the right because you
have a lived experience
so therefore it must be true um there's
this great guy on twitter um
greenberg he's a sociologist of some
kind of sociologist or
uh whatever exactly uh zach zach
goldberg
that's it okay some kind of jewishness
he's great yes fantastic but he did he
did data
on more black americans today
feel like there's discrimination that
did in 1965
and that is and actually the number of
even though the number of black men
in prison is down substantially
um by huge i think by 30 or 40 percent
the number
and arrests of black men are actually
down the number of black men who
report being harassed by the cops or
being arrested being targeted is up
so we by sitting there and saying
repeating constantly
you are you are a target you are it is
like creating
uh kind of some kind of social condition
in our country
i watch this hilarious video where an
atf
guy he's serving some kind of warrant i
don't know what he's doing he goes to
this woman's house because she bought a
shotgun
and he wants he's a white guy and he
wants to
check up on this shotgun purchase well
the lady is
sees a guy in plain clothes banging her
door and screaming you know yelling let
me in so she calls the police and says i
don't know who this guy is
the cops show up and they tell the guy
not to move well this guy's an atf agent
so he's like
yeah it's fine i got my they see the gun
and they're like they pull out their
guns don't
move get on the ground they're screaming
at them and this guy
resists he says just let me get my id
i'm a federal agent
for heaven's sake and they're like shut
up stop resisting
the cops are yelling stop resisting they
try putting in an suv and he's using his
head to stop them from getting in just
like george floyd did
and i'm like how amazing is it this
white atf agent
is being treated the same as we've seen
many of these other videos where they're
claiming it's racist
if you resist the police you're going to
make
everything substantially worse even if
the cops are wrong
and they often are a cop will stop you
you'll be the wrong person
this guy's an atf agent the cops are
stopping him they were wrong but if that
atf guy
immediately put his hands up and they
said what are you doing he says i'm an
atf agent serving papers you got your id
yes sir i do it's in my back pocket you
can go ahead and take it they'd be like
all right you're good
instead he starts yelling at him he
reaches for his waist huh
don't don't don't cause problems with
cops who don't know what's happening
this is this is the big issue i wanna
make this one more point everyone
assumes when a cop shows up he's psychic
he's omniscient omnipresent and they're
like i called the police the cops
going to show up and just know
everything cop shows up in the makai
bryant case he has no idea who called
no idea what's going on he just sees
people fighting somebody pulls a knife
back and he goes
no and he tries just a girl screaming
i'm gonna
bleeping stab you and while waving a
knife and he's going to sit there and
say no it's a butter knife it
you know it wouldn't make that big of a
of a difference it's
and then and the ironic thing was a 13
year old girl was murdered by a knife
attack by another 13 year old girl like
the following day
and i just wonder why those parents
never spoke up and said like i wish
we had an officer or that girl who
survived they don't want the cops
and i respect them i do you will respect
that they don't want the cops to save
their daughter who is being stabbed to
death
or the girl who survives in there
they're saying i'm thankful he showed up
no no if someone says i'm thankful the
cop saved my life
i respect that and if someone says we do
not want police in our neighborhood to
say okay
but i'm sure that they pro maybe they
didn't but i doubt if your daughter is
dead you don't
you sit there and say and actually when
they do polling most most people do want
cops in their neighborhood they do
that's true
so i doubt if they're not going to
defend the police if they're not going
to stand up for them while they're being
defunded and stripped and abolished and
all that stuff and i don't think they
yeah but you know here's the problem
it's that it's that minorities vote for
the democratic party which is controlled
by white liberals who institute their
beliefs
that they have perpetuated all
minorities don't actually get to govern
themselves in many different ways so
that's exactly that's
that's the sixth cycle that's happening
in most of these cities we got this guy
ben crump
you know he's he's this this lawyer who
goes to each and every one of these
events and tries to pump them up and
make them high profile so uh i actually
just did a a hit on fox news talking
about masks and stuff but
while they got me sitting there these
really cool things are these vans the
van pulls up to the house
and you open the door and it's like a
studio so people see me on tv and they
think i'm in like a building i'm in a
van
parking lot it's crazy that happens to
me in new york too i always think i'm
like i'm gonna
my band's gonna get towed while i'm on
air and it'll be the most
viral thing i ever do i'll be flying
back in my chair as my van's being towed
away
so anyway but it's their veterans their
van with their camera their setup
but uh at the beginning of the show they
were talking about ben crump and how he
once represented a family
when a 13 year old i think a young woman
was killed because the story was that
she was killed by a white man then once
he found out it was a black man
he just leaves he's like i'm out oh we
don't want to do that
so i bring this up because right now
this guy's out you know he goes out into
north carolina where this is going down
and he shows these these big cards where
it's like a human body and then he like
draws the bullet holes like he did with
he did the same thing with michael brown
and he
he's out there pushing this this
narrative and i'm kind of losing my
train of thought on this one about how
he's
who's perpetuating these crimes and to
advance himself basically yeah yeah
it's all about making money showing up
getting it to hear the moment
claiming something happened but you
don't see this guy
showing up in new york city when this
one this woman walked a black woman
walked up to another black woman put a
bolt in her head
yeah he didn't show up with this card
and draw a picture of where the bullet
was he didn't care at
all but here's here's my point i made a
point before but just in reference to
they don't want cops
did black lives matter protests for this
woman no did anyone say
we should have more police to help
protect us no not publicly
are there any high-profile democrats
coming out and saying we must stop this
violence no
because they don't care and if they
don't care i don't care either
they want to live that way i'm fine with
excitement i'm sure the individual
families of the neighborhood care that
there but there is a
whole entire system to build up these
stories that the media jumps on
that then activists jump on that money
gets involved in
but this all changed like with the al
sharpton boomer generation because what
used to happen with ethnic
politics in cities and major cities like
in new york is that
there were constituencies irish italian
black whatever
and they would demand certain things for
the whole community money for the same
patties they parade money and the
you know this project or whatever the
case is and the whole community would
benefit and then people like al sharpton
said no
give me a million dollar contract as
your spokesperson i will do better
representing the community but the
community itself will not advance
and that has been the model ever since
is that the spokesman does well
while the community suffers as opposed
to old school
politicians from 60 70 years ago where
they would throw you know
a hundred thousand dollars so the
community could have a parade or
whatever the case may be or school or
whatnot
now it's just let's advance a spokesman
and make them enormously wealthy and
then what happens after this guy leaves
i'm sure a whole lot of nothing well it
they probably leave the neighborhoods
destroyed
yeah struggling to recover yeah and this
guy gets millions of dollars remember
that girl that woman
in minneapolis who was like in tears
because she had nowhere to buy
her daughter's medicine because the only
cbs was burned down in like
yet of course they don't care but that's
that is that is so typical of
wealthy people with working-class people
is that oh yeah
isn't it funny no it's it is so typical
of all types of working-class people
um but it's especially perpetrated on
the poorest who will
who are stuck there the right today
sounds
functionally more left in many ways than
leftists i know it's true because i i
see leftists and they're like
redistribute wealth and i'm like that in
no way helps the workers support
themselves like it's just did you see
that empty
that child actor i've heard his name now
he's schneider schroeder he was yelling
at the
at the guy at costco for making him wear
a mask
whatever his name is and that is what
the left does though it's like hey let's
punch at the people who we have some
kind of power over because they're never
because there is a
dyna dynamic thing going on between the
billionaires the wealthy the
the companies that sponsor all their
events they make them wealthy
they will never actually target tim cook
for
displacing american workers for the h1b
system but they will always punch the
guy that they feel superior to during
occupy wall street they put up a shrine
to steve jobs
that is now when i say they i'm not
saying it was like an or like everyone
came and voted to do it
activists at occupy wall street created
a shrine around a tree for steve jobs
that is that's that is that's perfect i
mean that's and that is what they maybe
it was
maybe it was the one libertarian or like
handcap guy who was still in there
and he's like i love this stuff but he's
like
did anyone did anyone like tear it down
all right they had candles and like
people were like yes
did he just die yeah i think he died
around that time oh okay well it still
doesn't make any sense but like yeah
yeah but that's perfect that's a perfect
example because you want to
i mean but they depend on those
organizations how much money
did blm get from these billionaires who
wanted to feel good and they want to sit
there and write their uh you know back
a thousand years ago in the catholic
church you'd write you know your check
to sit there and get your sins washed
away they get their
white privilege washed away they do the
entire performative art program
a few people got very very wealthy over
this
system didn't change at all and we're
still going to take an h-1b visa worker
over
training you know a black person from
southern chicago or
wherever there's a lot of i just pulled
it up to be sure october 5th 2011 is
when steve jobs died
and one was occupy was september 17th
2011
okay so okay so he just died so like
it's october and i remember seeing the
shrine set up and i'm just like how
amazing
you know steve jobs one of the most
ruthless businessmen this this planet
has ever seen
just amazing how callous and nasty he
was
the stories of him screaming at people
ripping off ideas
and the people occupy wall street are
like cool
there you go and who had a massive
inequality from his workers
oh definitely my massive inequality but
but you know listen if that's what
you're sitting there and you because
because apple's the thing to do and it's
part of their identity program and these
were a lot of
occupy walsh were wealthy kids from
trust fund families who needed an
identity the ones organizing it were
yeah i know them personally yeah and
they
they didn't they did not go home to sit
there and and you know
have to struggle work being a
blue-collar worker well this is the
funniest thing about occupy is that you
had a bunch of people sleeping in the
park with no voice
being told to shut up and then the
people organizing it went home to
brooklyn to their apartments
were paid for by their parents yeah yeah
yeah yeah and they would steal stuff and
and when donations would come in take it
and be like but i need this
it's better that i take it than you know
other people and they would hoard stuff
really yeah it was so crooked the whole
thing
i just i just love the idea that in like
20 years there'll be all these books
from the activists about what really
happened well there'll be university
professors by then
right they'll be lying i was there and
i'll tell you what happened and they
will
lie out of their asses about what really
went down at occupy wall street it was
crooked it was so crooked but that's
what's happening blm the woman
has like five homes now you're right i
mean she's got five homes now she's not
housing any
you know homeless people with mental
health problems who are homeless in
washington dc
well she's she's just uh she is
collecting houses
so that she can at some point distribute
them
among the bernie sanders i mean they got
like
you know one day all these houses will
be available for people but it's i
kind of just point something out like
people need to understand bernie he's
got what three houses
three and this lady's got five yes it is
it is it is insane to think you can
maintain you need staff for this
like i wonder if people actually think
about one of bernie's homes was
inherited by his like wife's family
but the other one is it's a vacation
home there's a vacation on the water
in the river in vermont which is a
million-dollar home but people need to
understand this especially when it
pertains to like homelessness and stuff
you can't just have a house sitting
empty you can't
there's got to be upkeep what happens if
you if you if this lady's got like five
houses right
what happens if uh pipe bursts yeah does
the house just
fly out and destroy yeah someone's got
to be maintaining it there's got to be
someone mows the grass someone probably
does exactly yeah
absolutely there's got to have people
maintaining this stuff it costs money to
maintain these buildings
and they're probably also not black or
employed i mean imagine if she sits
there and hired like
you know a hispanic illegal alien to sit
there and maintain it instead of
at least employing a black person to do
a job
that would be the i guess the bare
minimum you sit there i don't care so
much about the race but how much you
want to bet she is employing
undocumented or oh yeah absolutely
not and that is the hypocrisy of all
these organizations that sat there and
and do everything they can to displace
american labor because it's quote
unquote expensive
well and get foreign laborers as fast as
they can
and they're the first ones to sit there
and say there's mass inequality well who
is creating
it is like it is this is a quote from
the book called mountain but it's like
being in control of the weather and
sitting inside the rain and saying it's
raining
yeah of course no no you know i can't
curse but yeah exactly
no joke well let's let's talk about the
political ramifications because we got
this philly d.a race
yes it is i've heard about it but you
were saying something crazy so it's
larry
kr krasner is his name he is the
district attorney he was a former def
uh defense attorney and a public defense
attorney
and he was a source back canada he was
soft on crime he
did not um he didn't charge a series of
crimes around the blm
riots including like you know breaking
into windows destroying public
properties during private property
didn't prosecute anything and now he's
being uh primary by the name of carlos
vega who is a um prosecutor
as a career prosecutor who's puerto
rican descent um and he
is being challenged uh in the district
and if this happens it will be the first
soros-backed candidate to
lose after being elected but there's
been a huge surge of murder in
philadelphia like it is
oh yeah i mean we we don't we didn't
only get 90s like television shows last
year we got 90
crime rates in last year and this is
definitely one of them and look at
philadelphia i mean these people they
have to live with it and they have to
deal with it so i mean
this is this is a democratic primary by
the way so there's no republicans right
it's just democrats this is what's been
happening across the
across the country the cops will arrest
one of these extremists who are
burning things down or smashing things
or punching cops and then the
soros-backed da's or these leftists will
just be like there's no crime here i
didn't see anything
and then you get somebody who like
didn't wear a mask at a burger king and
they
prison like banging the gathering they
start beating them like yeah no in
public
no and that's and but they go after the
ones who don't who can't fight
i mean that's the thing and they don't
want to sit there and they don't and
they want to pretend that they're
that they're you know protecting these
people but in the meantime you're having
this lady
and you know who doesn't have a cvs now
to get her insulin from or whatever she
drug she was getting
and that's the problem going you know
and you're making life much worse the
people you are
pro promising to protect so i don't know
what i'm trying was trying to see if the
election was happening right now i think
that both
vote tallies are coming in about now but
i don't know you know it's probably too
early but
it'll be interesting to see if prasner
goes down because there's dozens of
there's one in la there's one in uh
there's kim fox
kim yeah wasn't she back in chicago yeah
right she and she let jesse smell let go
yes yes talk about kids she's a
woman of the people because if there's
anyone who's really suffering this life
it's jesse small out
that was the most insane story i
i think i've ever heard and you had wow
he's at it's it's what was it like 20
degrees in chicago
no it was like like in the single digits
and there's these two white guys waiting
outside
subway it's subway sandwiches he's by
he's by
the nbc building downtown chicago which
is like a business area and there's like
very few people by the way wait can i
say
he is a actor from the show empire which
no white people watched
like i mean no white people watch the
show empire i would never i did not
hear about i never heard of him until i
saw this i loved the joke where they
were like
yes the two trump supporters who are
familiar with the d-list actor
from the show the show empire right yeah
i'm like there's zero chance i was like
this is
this isn't real right it's amazing to me
how dumb some of these people
are that he couldn't come up with a
better story where he could have just
said a car drove by and a guy yelled
this is moga country and threw a bottle
at him
you know and then he called the cops he
sat in his apartment with the noose
around his neck
for like a half an hour until they shut
up he just sat there with the
noose around his neck i mean it that
doesn't raise a flight i don't know i
i think tops were clear i have never had
a newspaper on my neck but i bet you if
i did i wouldn't sit there with i don't
like wearing my tie
like for one more second then i have to
we wanted to make sure the cops came out
exactly
like yeah i'm just going to sit there
and i don't you know what you know what
i really loved was that like apparently
there was footage
of him with the brothers like walking up
to the area like the day before or
something and like pointing at it
like this is where we're gonna do it
exactly and sitting there and saying oh
you know an eight-degree weather these
and it's saying
and in full seriousness he believed that
no everyone would just
believe him 100. but they did no i mean
no most people did not believe him when
you get
the was it the big bang theory or
whatever like some show they
all like he doesn't have a career
nowadays
well that's because he got he got caught
yeah but at the time
you had all these photos coming out you
had remember when uh um
the the actor what's called the actor
paige so to avoid offending anybody that
that the person who played
uh um shadow cat and x-men okay
uh oh uh yeah yeah paige yeah well i'm
trying to avoid being offensive to
literally anybody
former artist formerly known as ellen
page there we go i think that still
might be disrespectful but uh
she was he was formerly known as ellen
page all right technically
well uh paige was on what like was it
whose show was it
uh just like really angrily being like
and like yelling about what happened
man imagine being one of these people
right now where they're like you know
the cdc is just very you know
droll you can take off your masks now
and then you're like
my identity just like a lack of
self yeah so you have these people who
go on tv after the justice smallett
thing who are just like screaming and
like shaking
just believing the world is this insane
place well
if you're not if you're not an
interesting person and most people are
not interesting and no offense to them
but they're not interesting
and you need to wrap yourself an
identity usually you know
generation two ago you either had kids
by about your early 30s you were married
or you had a
career you're building and that was kind
of your whole identity maybe belong to a
civic association
of some sort like i don't know some kind
of bowling like whatever the case would
be
that was your identity and it was
wrapped in actually doing something now
if you're like a 35 year old person and
you're either you know in your mom's
basement still because you can't get a
job or you're a single woman and you
have 15 degrees
you know and you can't get a job or
whatever you of course you wrap yourself
in a bigger identity it's how you make
yourself
interesting in some way you know you
know you know i wonder it kind of feels
like we're all
in this pot and it's being sh you know
shaken up really hard
and like people like us are just sitting
in the corner just like yeah i get it
yes
but there are some people where every
change is making their heads like
they're stressed like the blood pressure
on these like
well there is some mentally ill people
on this one oh yeah yeah mental illness
emotionally on the left on the left oh
yeah this study is done with it and yeah
um goldberg said that that was good yeah
and there is a lot of mental illness on
the left and
it's probably self-induced at some point
i mean i don't know but there's probably
something
what i mean is i feel like you've got
the you know fauci for instance
and he's like you you don't got to wear
masks no
you don't it's the you know you might
protect you from a droplet and then
everyone listens and then a month later
it's like you definitely gotta wear
masks
if these people are playing simon says
with this guy so i'm sitting back just
like
uh-huh what's the next thing and it was
um who was the guy on
uh on rogan was it uh bill burr
yeah where he was like i just turn on
the tv and it says do i wear a mask or
not i just do it with a tv set it's like
billboard yeah
okay that sounds like that and uh that's
what he said and i'm like these people
are playing simon says to this guy if
you're if you're
in whatever bubble whatever world we're
in i'm sitting here like this like oh is
that the rule now is that is that what
we're doing i'm just going to mind my
own business
it's flipped and changed too much i'm
chilling but imagine you are one of
these people
and they tell you wear a mask first they
say don't wear masks they say wear mask
then they say oh oh no the vaccine will
never get out oh no the vaccine's done
oh oh
now now even if you eat the vaccine you
got to wear a mask for no apparent
reason you cannot take the mask off
these people are like being flipped like
pancakes over and over again
and they're probably at some point like
their blood pressure must be through the
roof
because all they know is i trust the
authorities i trust
the elites i trust the establishment but
they keep getting
like like i don't know what simon says
with vouchers i don't know how much of
it is like i
hate trump and i want to show how great
i am in hating republicans conservatives
i'm going to still wear my mask and how
much was i genuinely fear from my health
because there are those people who have
genuine like paranoia fear and this is
all like coming out
and how much was like this is no this is
part of my identity i wear a man like
david hogg who's like i'm going to wear
a mask because i don't want to be
because i don't want to be a
conservative so i'm going to sit there
and just you know
and it's i'm just saying it's also not
healthy for you to wear a mask all the
time like you can't like can't
get dirty yeah
i'm wondering at what point do these
people just drop to their knees and like
their eyes go out
opposite direction they go because you
cannot
follow no rules you know what i mean
like so the woke left
will say women is offensive because not
inclusive so you've got to say
wemmickson
but why mixing is offensive because it
changes women and now it's exclusive
how do you live in a world where there's
no rules if you do not have mental
fortitude
your brain is probably going to explode
at some point yeah
you're gonna fall down and just scream
in combat especially people lose their
mind they panic they fall down they
can't
they can't shoot they're just laying
there you have to force them down on the
ground i was talking to forrest about
this a little bit yesterday as army
ranger for a while
like you just you just pushed them down
on the ground and continue to do your
job
without them don't pay them attention
they're screaming they're loud
unfortunately these people have access
to social media are making a big loud
noise
and they run the institutions too yeah
and when laws get made
after because of panic that's disturbing
that's really disturbing yeah
yeah and that's and but that's when they
use it see here's my frustration with
the right after cove but kovid was like
the problem with the right is like we do
things like we complain about public
education for 45 years saying it's a
horrible
horrible institution with lots of
fallacies which it is it's true
and then they shut down every school in
the country and our our go-to
knee-jerk reaction is let's open the
public schools again the thing we've
hated for 45 years no let's go right
back to that it's not like hey
maybe we could like you know give every
parent a certain amount of money if they
want to homeschool or send their kids to
a private school or a religious school
whatever the case is
and we'll massively change our education
this will be the opportunity this is the
crisis we'll use to fundamentally alter
education the left always does that the
right
never does that did you see that and
they're idiots for doing you see the
tweet from the gop
where they were like you know thousands
of mothers have chosen to stay
with their kids yes oh my god i was like
what is
wrong with you people i'm like this is
what we always
talked about like oh my god they have a
parent at home how
wonderful they've they they the the
overton window has gone so far
left the republicans are outraged that
more women aren't leaving their kids
within daycare and going to work
yeah and and you would think that this
is the time to sit there and really
restructure society friendly friendly
ibrawitz uh
who i'm a really big fan of she was like
oh it's so great that there's no more
tourists in new york city because i hate
taurus but also the new york city
economy just crashed
and uh she's like they're like we're
gonna get back to normal normal wasn't
great we could actually make things
better but the diff but if you're not a
visionary person
and a lot of people on the left i give
them credit are visionary people they
have a dream of what america is going to
look like it's not the dream i really
you know
subscribe to but it's their dream those
on the right they don't have
you know a vision and i say this
politician all the time when i consult
with them i say
tell me what if you were going to run
whatever you're running for mayor
congress president whatever it is if
you're going to run whatever you're
going to run
for a decade tell me what it looks like
and i don't want to hear the words
free market liberty or freedom i don't
hear any buzzwords
i want you to describe to me where i can
close my eyes i can walk through a town
that you want to be mayor of
and i want to see what that town will
look like that is drastically different
than the world i have now
and if you don't have that vision you
can't explain it to me who spends my
whole life in here
you can't explain anybody else to be
fair it's true
you know they probably don't have a
vision of what the world should look
like they just have you know certain you
know platitudes
tax cuts for apple yeah yeah but but the
the the creativity or like the ideas of
the left in their vision
you know look they they might have a
vision but it's like
hovercrafts and unicorns flying through
the air oh it's it's
it's a crazy vision haters producing
free cheeseburgers and everyone's fit
and healthy
yeah if you put lsd in your oatmeal
that's the visions you get but that's
that's not like that's that doesn't mean
that you shouldn't have an alternative
aside from oh we'll just make enough tax
cuts that the world will be better
there is something in between there is a
vision of education is
really important a lot of people care
about it and we've complained for half a
century about it
and we shut down every public school in
the country and we thought of no
alternatives besides open up every
public school in the country back up
that's problematic that shows you don't
have that means a serious lack of vision
and leadership i was i was excited when
the schools got all got shot
schools are trash and i was like
homeschool your kids these pods things
that sounds great yeah where they
like you get one parent to like watch
the 40 kids or whatever and then they
trade off
yes that's illegal in some states in
some communities and that should be the
number one thing people should campaign
on making sure that if you have a former
math teacher
on your block and sheik is not allowed
to sit there and bring all the kids from
the block to sit there and learn math
that's horrible and that's what i'm
thinking the governor should executive
orders immediately and done that but
they didn't because
you know people between the years
they're not they don't have a lot of
things going on there so i guess
that's one of the biggest problems we
have in the culture war is you've got
people who are opposed to something and
people who want something psychotic
yeah and you don't have the alternative
to sit there and say what is
what does you know what would benefit
america that you could provide and use
the government
use the power of government in some
positive sense they do this in other
countries on the right
and i get that america has some
attachment to the idea of you know
liberty and but i think that most people
do want some kind of security they do
want some kind of vision from their
leaders
and you know that's why we slowly lose
every institution
they erode everything across the board
and and if you don't i mean the one
thing that we've kind of won on his guns
as you mentioned i mean
the right has one on guns but that's
because you had a group of people who
were
singularly focused who had a vision the
vision was you can buy a gun without a
license
and when in 1986 there was only one
state in the country that had that law
which was vermont
of all places and now it's like over 18
states that have that law that you know
this is really crazy i just learned this
today because uh we've got another story
and we'll we'll lead off with this real
quick but um there's a story out of
arkansas about a guy who stops a mass
shooting
and i think it's really important to
talk about because had there
had this man not have been there then
every outlet would be oh no another
tragedy another mass shooting from
you know crazy you know far right white
but he
he killed i believe uh one person and
then a guy grabbed his rifle and
stopped him it's a horrifying horrifying
event but i mean
in in life people do crazy things this
can happen
so in in looking up the story and i'll
jump to in a second i looked up
constitutional carry in the u.s and the
funny thing is
we the gun the gun rights advocates have
been winning yeah
like and i mean like winning winning
yeah they just started in texas
they have this map here and you can see
it's uh going through the years
1986 vermont i mean in 1986 you almost
couldn't get a gun anywhere
it was may issue across the country
meaning states could be like screw you
you don't get a concealed carry permit
now it's beyond concealed carry it's
straight up many states are about being
constitutional carry
so we have here right like i mean look
at this the blue that you can see on the
screen is shall issue meaning
if you apply for a concealed carry they
have to give it to you it can be
kind of prohibitively bureaucratic
you're going to get it
so there's only some areas of new of the
you know of the northeast and california
and maryland that are
may issue meaning you can apply and they
can tell you to screw off rude
but all of most of the country now
except for
new jersey long island and hawaii those
are
no issue in practice they call it
meaning you're not getting a gun yeah
but in most of the country you can get a
gun and more importantly
all of this green it's like
constitutional carry yeah you can walk
in now texas is about to do it
texas is about to pass constitutional
carry that means you can walk into a gun
shop
you do a background check a lot of i
guess these democrat people don't
understand
you have to do a background check
sometimes they tell you come back in a
week sorry
sometimes they say you're being
researched it'll take 15-20 minutes
sometimes they say they've cleared you
but after your background check is done
they you can buy your gun and then in
these constitutional carry states you
can walk out the door with it yeah
tennessee as well
they're doing the same thing yeah
they're they they are now
it's it's brought across the country and
that's because they had i mean the nra
was part of it but gun owners of america
and these organizations on the activists
had one vision and it was i'm going to
buy it be able to buy a gun wherever i
want to and they have been successful it
is
you know not every vision is this grand
scheme but the
right had that on on guns and they don't
have it on a large scoop thing and so
i'll tell you one of one of the visions
that i've certainly been having over the
past year this is a story from
bearingarms.com
armed citizen uses rifle to stop
attempted mass shooting now for the most
part i
told everyone the story already they say
it was an 87 year old woman
there was a guy who was yelling at
people get out here come out here
everyone go to the building right now
when an older woman went out to uh two
women went out
to console him they saw that he had a
weapon they fled
he went into the apartments of one of
the women and he took her life
at some point there was a neighbor who
grabbed a rifle of his own
and fatally shot the the killer the
police haven't
released many details of the incident we
don't know yet what motivated arnold to
kill his elderly neighbor
it's clear that as a resident amber lane
told local media there could have been
many more victims were it not for the
quick response by the armed citizen
here's what happens the democrat types
and i say this specifically because
leftists like actual socialists they
love guns they want guns they want a
revolution so they advocate for guns
karl marx said
keep your guns so these democrat
establishment types these elites are
like no one should have guns but the
police oh by the way defund the police
sure whatever i digress
they they want to take away the weapons
from the people then a criminal will get
a gun
commit a mass tragedy and they'll say
see this is exactly why we're saying
take away your guns
they'll make gun laws more restrictive
which will make the problem continually
worse
and keep using the problem they created
to justify
making the problem worse so in my vision
people have a right to keep and bear
arms and when unfortunate situations
happen people have right to defend
themselves
that's what i see a department of gun
services where when you turn 16 you go
in
you fill the paperwork they bring you to
the range you do a standard shooting
test and then you get your free
government issued
ar or handgun i'm somewhat kidding
but the point is i'm saying i think
people should be
uh trained should understand gun safety
from a young age
and should keep and bear arms don't they
do that in switzerland like you have to
have a gun in the household
they say that and we talked about that
yesterday i'm not sure how true that is
okay
it's like i think it's an urban legend
okay that's partially true
so yeah yeah in switzerland i don't
think it is required but it is very
commonly accepted that you will be
practicing shooting young people do it
they used to have like a boys shooting
club
obviously now they take girls and
everything but they train them they
teach them to use it as a tool this is
something that i was arguing about it's
like this is something that you need to
respect
but it also needs to be culturally
accepted that you're going to have a gun
it shouldn't be weird they did it after
world war ii right or during world war
ii so they armed everybody so if the
nazis ever invaded everyone had a
firearm
i think i don't know maybe i'm i'm wrong
but and and and i know
people who listen to this show are going
to be back autumns bring up the same
argument again but uh because you have
you maybe
have not heard it my argument is like
you know people drive cars and i don't
think they're going to hit me with their
car
sometimes people hit people with cars
sometimes on purpose but uh
i feel totally comfortable with
everybody being armed so long as
they understand actually i feel much
safer with them understanding gun safety
and having a well look how many people
actually have guns and look how
relatively few murders there are and
look at me i mean bill of cars and i'm
relatively you know minor accidents
there are but people are on their
smartphones like playing video game
texting while walking our street is
amazing that aren't like thousands of
bodies scattered across major streets
but it does happen like people generally
are you know and there are some people
who are
off their rock or like the vegas shooter
or whoever who would like want to commit
horrible accidents well we don't know
enough about that guy actually so okay
so whatever the columbine kits whatever
the case is there are people who do want
to create
a terrible situations and um and
they do exist but they're always going
to exist i mean that crazy
people will do crazy things yeah the
argument from the left is that
because there is a small fraction of
crazy people
the overwhelming majority 99.999
shouldn't be able to defend themselves
that makes no sense you know who the
worst you know lieutenant governor of
north carolina has have you heard of
this guy he's a
rob robinson is his last name i can't
remember he gave a speech they were
trying to do gun control
in his local county and he gave a speech
i went viral
mark robinson saying that you know your
your
criticisms of of people committing
crimes always how do we hurt
the law how we how do we hurt the people
you know abiding by the law
he's a big black man rural place has a
big rural accent
and uh great great great man and he's
like i am the majority because majority
are law abiding gun owners
not i'm not a minority and this is the
problem as you say how do i hurt the
majority immediately not not ever go
after them
none of these things these laws they
propose hurts the criminals yeah
it's it's just like what we're gonna
make it worse for people who actually
obey the law
yeah and until we end up with like the
minority port where you can sit there
and go into the future it's not gonna
it's not gonna change
a good point that was brought up by our
guest yesterday forest cooper was that
suppressors for instance make
firing rifles safer those get banned
because
people have no idea what they're talking
about or they get restricted under
the nfa yeah and the problem is with the
media is and i worked i used to work at
the washington examiner
you know many a few years ago like five
years ago and um
most people and that was the right way
media people don't own guns in the media
especially like
new york media dc media they don't own
guns they never fire them
wasn't like the washington post who had
a picture of like a chainsaw attached to
a machine gun or anything
today it was like literally a chainsaw
next to it like
that yeah it was it was the most insane
thing ever like clearly a
a weapon that would never ever work it
was like the star wars
and this was a serious like combination
of possibly deadly weapons that they you
know people could have
we got it we got it we gotta look at
this november 8 2017 usa today issues
clarification
after depicting rifle with a chainsaw
fan oh my god
i gotta say i'm just i love this the guy
i can't remember which news outlet he
worked for maybe it was washington post
he said firing an ar-15 gave him a
temporary form of ptsd and get the hell
out of here
get the hell out of here dude i could i
always say this imagine if the guy maybe
if you're a
bad shot like it would be you'd be
humiliated by it but ptsd is
i i as as i've you know gotten more
heavily involved in
you know gun ownership experienced
firing at 12 gauge
and firing ar with five you know in five
five six
and if this guy thinks that the the 556
was
was giving was that bad i and that's
that's the actual weapon of war
556 nato then i couldn't imagine him
going small game hunting
yeah he'd be like ah my arm it hurts
what's happening i actually find i find
smaller guns
i don't like handguns at all because it
doesn't feel real like i don't feel like
i feel like i'm shooting
with a gun when i'm shooting a rifle i'm
shooting a handgun i'm like this feels
like a toy like i really don't this
doesn't feel safe like i feel like i
would like accidentally blow my own head
off
but like a rifle you have some kind of
command of it
and if yeah if he had that problem i
mean that's a lot that's uh
that's the man who cries after sex
there's no way he doesn't
there's like validity to uh loud
explosions and noises causing like
long-term stress they called it shell
shock after world war one for people in
the trenches but
yeah i think as a human you really that
was our artillery shell like coming next
for months for months at a time right
yeah we have a duty as humans to
to to learn how to handle large
explosions i went
like we should just be able to deal with
that well i
i saw a car bomb went off next to him it
was shooting a gun once circumstance
with an instructor
safety gear on people do demolition like
for a living
across the whole country and never have
this the myth busters would blow stuff
up every day and you know in the mojave
desert for fun for a tv show the whole
earth
rocks when they're demolishing a giant
sky rise and you're like six blocks away
that's that's
bro we we knocked down a tree in my
backyard when we were in the philly area
we had to get a tree room because it was
dying
and it was like out of fungus or
something and so they're like what we're
going to do is
we're going to go up they climb to the
top they cut chunks of the top off then
measure
and they say okay we're going to knock
it down straight this way it's going to
slam into the ground
though it was like an earthquake it was
crazy when that massive tree came down i
did not realize
the like shake that you would feel was
like whoa
it was like an explosion it was crazy
and then we had someone across the
street the same thing and one day i'm
sitting there like boom the whole house
chicks i'm like wow
this guy couldn't handle firing a gun
yeah and there's a photo
of a little girl i love it the little
girl with the pink you know
yeah but uh i i i've been to
a bunch of different places around
around the world with civil unrest and
conflict
and i've been in a bunch of riots and
there was one point where i was in new
york
i was walking down broadway in brooklyn
and a car back fired
and then i immediately got an adrenaline
rush it was like whoa
because i was so used to being on the
ground in these conflict situations that
when the bang went off it was like
that's when you were like in action mode
and then i was like kind of laughing at
myself i was like wow man
it's like i gotta chill out i guess
because i'm getting yeah but like i mean
there are people who like live in like
syria during the revolution
and like they undergo horrible things on
a daily basis and they don't sit there
and feel the need to write an
op-ed about how they were emotionally
triggered by every moment of their life
they just
you know you move on it's a shotgun you
shot once if you watch videos from these
war zones
many of them in more urban areas you
will see people literally just doing
their daily business
right you'll hear gunshots you'll see a
guy like just walking carrying like a
basketball
well that was old new york new york i
mean i grew up there my whole life i'm a
eighth generation new yorker it
makes you tough if you live there your
whole life and you just are unfazed by
certain things there was like a failed
bombing there a couple of years ago and
like
and like the press ran there and there
are people like they're like can you
stop like no i'm
on my way to work what are you talking
about it was just happened like i'm on
my work right
that that's what it makes you and i
guess if you're a very fragile person
who's been very comfortable
your entire life like the most minimal
thing just as there and shakes you i
think more than that he had an agenda to
push to them oh of course yeah and i was
reading about switzerland and far from
being a response to world war
ii the reason that germany did not
invade switzerland was because every man
has to be in the military and yes they
do have guns in every single home
they're issued by the government which
is stems
there's a there's a town the next
right-wing president him is the head of
the department of gun ownership
gun services there's a town in georgia
that mandates gun ownership kennesaw oh
really yeah yeah
wow i know that that's important oh yeah
that's neat mandates i want to go there
this is the way do you get to pick your
gun out or does it say
you have to own one but you how do they
give you one okay but you don't they
don't sit there and say it has to be
this style of gun you could say any gun
oh i don't know i got it i don't know
that's interesting if they say like
you know it's like north korea if they
have certainly had a hairstyle but
they're certain that's why i'm wondering
so
there's like five to choose from yes i
think i think at the department of gun
services
they would have like you know two rifles
to choose from and like two different
handguns
yeah and then just but you know they're
going to be like garbage government
issue yeah you don't want that yeah
like soviet union stuff like the 60s i'm
like yeah yeah government cheese
[Laughter]
you walk in they're like we've got a
captured ak you know
you gonna use it the whole thing falls
apart it's like exactly that's smart but
it's free
with the tracking mechanisms and you
have to turn in you're gonna get a new
2023 smart gun i like to listen to your
talking
i think i think it'll be a great
equalizer to give everybody access right
now look the rich people will have the
really great of course high tech stuff
but then the people the regular people
can be able to walk in and you know get
a handgun
but you know what you were mentioning
before box of ammo too we were talking
before about like policing and
everything like that
and the defunded police is coming out of
a lot of the woke laughs and especially
the wealthy left who live in private
gated communities
a big thing about the police that people
don't understand is it's not only
something about social about safety it's
about
climbing up the economic ladder my
family my dad said super poor 11 kids
super irish catholic
every boy became a cop because that's
your only avenue to join the middle
class
if you cut off that avenue now in every
major city in this country
basically uh policemen are majority
minority most
are non-white you this is the avenue to
become part of the middle class for
people who have no other way of going to
college and spending 40 000 years and
doing it
by cutting off the ability to become a
cop because the alternative now is to
become a sociologist and you know back
of 200 grand in debt
by cutting off the ability to be part of
the middle class
the alternative for social security for
these gated communities is going to be
uh private security guards without a
pension probably making maybe 25
an hour and that's it with no ability to
retire it keeps it actually suppresses
people
poor people even more both in urban
communities by making them less safe
but also cutting off the opportunity to
join the middle class
i know that's a totally random thing but
the riots are the same thing they
destroy
residential neighborhoods they destroy
businesses and the altar while they can
buy up cheap property and then sit down
and wait until the problem but if you
care if you're supposed to be a working
class people this
this is what you're supposed to actually
care about is how does the working class
how does the working poor
make it in this country and and advance
themselves to some
not everyone's gonna be a billionaire
and everyone needs to be a billionaire
or a millionaire but some
level some floor of comfortability where
you know their kids will do better
themselves and they'll have some
respectability at the end of their life
if that's the end goal as it should be
for any socio-economic policy
this does the complete opposite yes it
destroys
property but it also cuts off the path
to the middle class we we were talking a
moment ago about you know
leftist gun control and i wanted to pull
up this story this is from
fox news parkland activist calls out
media for not aiding gun reform efforts
under biden after doing so under trump
suddenly you're just an angry leftist
who will never be happy with
anything that cameron caskey said i
don't think cameron caskey is a leftist
at all uh leftist he's just a theater
kid he's a
yeah he's theater kid but he's more like
an establishment democrat so i
i don't see him as like a socialist i
don't think he posts this stuff maybe he
does maybe i'm wrong
but there's a big difference between the
leftists like the antifa types who are
literally like
wanting an insurrection and buying a
bunch of guns and
quoting marks all day when mark said you
know under no pretext shall arms and
ammunition be surrendered
the workers must frustrate this if with
force if necessary he he's just an
establishment guy right so these are
like the elites these are
the the um the uh shocked
nobility of capital city going like egad
the people have gone
how could they he's surprised now that
the media has completely abandoned him
now that joe biden is president and they
don't need his vote anymore
it's funny how that happens isn't it he
said quote
right now this very moment is very
complicated it's a very
complicated time for gun violence
prevention activists
they're not but anyway because with
biden and white house the media does not
want to aid
us in demanding stronger gun reforms
because whatever joe biden does is
suddenly the right thing to do caskey
said
when donald trump was the president
calling for an assault weapons ban and
saying that the measures
that he was putting in place were not
nearly enough was a very popular opinion
now if you're calling for an assault
weapons ban certainly just an angry
leftist
who will never be happy with anything
that was always true
they were using you to try and get
donald trump out of office
the assault weapon ban would have never
done anything and that's why your ideas
don't make sense
but it's no surprise that the media is
like we're out yeah they didn't want to
help them in the first place
well and now i mean i tweeted this
because i think the washington post had
an op-ed about how
uh biden's uh white house is the most
blue-collar white house in history which
is
like completely not true but i guess if
you have a job you're considered
blue-collar
and i said you know clinton got fellatio
from one intern
now the entire press corps is doing it
for biden left and right they love him
or they love what he's representing or
allowing to happen yeah
biden is the greatest president of this
or any generation the greatest enough
times people start to believe it
could you imagine the people who you
know don't watch the news anymore who
actually believe that
where you've got a guy who goes on tv
and he says true in another shop at a
pressure
and they think this guy is capable of
running a country and and
the thing is he's remarkably radical
like i mean
biden is far more radical than i even
thought that he would be he's
very very far to the left with things
that he's doing and
people still consider him a moderate and
it's just bizarre to me and he's like
this fragile old guy that they're like
oh no he's finding somebody
no he's what the things that he's doing
he just got rid of that monument
like that monument ban who was sitting
there saying oh man
i was going to destroy a monument today
but trump did that executive order and
he was like no i'll be your advocate you
could destroy monuments again why
like why like why was that the thing
that he was like i gotta do this
and maybe it's just been the face of
trump i don't know but it's it's bizarre
i do i do think you you're you're being
a little unfair to joe biden
all right yeah so i i wanna i wanna read
you i want to read you a quote it's very
profound
and um inspirational something that joe
biden said that's going to make you at
least
you got to give him some credit joe
biden said the best way to get something
done
if you if you hold it near and dear to
you
that you like to be able to anyway
is that a real quote yes when was that
recent i don't know
that's i think you can listen to him say
it i wonder if i can find the video i
hate it
it's worse than the way i read it i was
that was a commencement speech problem i
was trying
to read that as if it weren't all right
let's see if this is it can we play it
i'm a very very practical
guy yeah okay
i can't make it any louder though huh
i don't think can anybody hear this i
don't think they can hear it oh because
it's i can't make it any louder than it
is that sucks um that's a process
let me try and find a better video yeah
he uh
yeah his whole thing about any i i don't
know i think that biden
is bryden's has these grand like you
know proposals
that are large and trillions of dollars
and that's what you do
after you're lyndon johnson and win 46
states and that's after you when you're
fdr and you win you know i guess there
was only 48 states at the time 47 states
this time so 45
or or reagan after he won 49 or nix
after 49.
this is what he did where he won by 45
000 votes in three states and a 50 50
senate and law seats in the house
i i think it's because he knows he's not
going to be there for very long and do
you remember when i think it was
somebody in the press who was talking
about how great it is that they can use
biden to make it look like what they're
doing is not
radical he's like everyone thinks he's
super nice but we're being able to get
all this stuff done but isn't it funny
how uh kamala has
far lower approval ratings than he does
i mean
it's not surprising at all she's the
hillary clinton factor where she's not a
likeable person
she's just got that natural that laugh
is rough
but she has that natural thing and yeah
maybe he's just likable and people
and people will sit there and excuse it
but it is really
horrendous and if you know if we go into
next year i mean that
i mean his approval ratings i think are
at 52 51 53 about and his disapprovals
are in the mid 40s which is
very average for you know 100-day 128th
president
okay god you can play it i got it you
got it
no i don't i don't think it's working i
don't think people aren't yeah but i can
hear it no no i don't i can hear it too
but yeah i don't think it's getting
picked up on the uh
live stream yeah on the live stream or
whatever oh well too bad you can't hear
it
but uh yeah so the best way to get
something done if you if you hold near
and dear to you that you uh
yum like to be able to anyway and that's
and that's not that's not uh his like
tick that he has where he can't speak
that's not stutter forgot what he was
saying
can i just on whitehouse.gov
yeah it's actually it's actually here
transcribed oh my god
it's actually transcribed on
whitehouse.gov exactly
it is a a quote from joe biden yeah and
that will never be
i mean that will never be looked at all
of his
you know biden isms the way that trump
used to say like everything was the
greatest the most wonderful the best
that was i mean mocked ridiculously
biden's
falling apart the issue with biden is
that
every journalist does this including
conservative journalists
joe biden will say something like we we
got uh
uh you know lumber prices are too high
we
we got to get lumber prices you know uh
down
and then the conservatives will write
joe biden said quote we got to get
lumber prices down yes
no he didn't he's not um trinidad shot
at a pressure
yeah everything speaks like fog horn
yeah yeah i mean and and everyone says
they're insane no that's absolutely true
uh and you know my grandfather died of
parkinson's and my grandmother's
dementia i'm very used to
and when he had park parkinson's he got
lube dementia i know dementia i'm not
like a doctor whatever
and i don't think that he has any
advanced stages of of it but even if
he's the perfectly most healthy person
in the world
he is a man of a particular age and you
know
yeah there are a handful of men who go
into their 80s you know
the clinton eastwoods of their of the
world they can still sit there and work
and operate
but joe biden is not that he's 87 right
88. no no he's
79. 79. 7980. he's either nine or eight
eight seven eight maybe i mean he's
aging decrepit
he's definitely not uh he's definitely
spry i don't say decrepit about many
lives
but that's but he is but he's only five
years older than trump
and look at like the even the last two
years his exhaustion level is just over
two well he stops working in a lot or he
like he has he can't be around the press
after like a certain hours a day doesn't
answer questions
you guys need to look look this up on
your phones real quick cause i'm gonna
show everyone who's watching
there's an article from the onion stress
presidency already ages biden 10 years
yes and he looks like a mummy he looks
desiccated yeah it's just like a rotten
corpse just like
10 years that's
kind of that's what it feels like the
last two years is just
it's just aged him his voice is so much
more tired
what you need to understand my friend is
that as you're older and older it's an
exponential decline
yeah you know i guess the older you get
the faster your decline is
you know you look at there there's i'm
not going to name anybody but there are
some people that i used to you know look
up to who are old and passed on and it's
like you could really see that decline
happen man faster and faster yeah yeah
yeah it's not one of those people in
your 60s to your 70s
people in general most people i've
witnessed go to that age range don't
decline very much 70s to 80s is a
big slow down and 80s to 90s now is
where he's approaching
i mean very few people are betty white
it's like movement
or william or william shatner like yeah
i think he's actually like data from
yeah
yeah or like dick van dyke there are a
handful flores leachman
there's a handful of uh people mel
brooks
who like in their 90s stellar better
than i am in my 30s
um he is not the president united states
currently and also it's where when you
look at foreign countries
like the president austria is my age yes
and you're like or like the like the
chancellor
no no austria oh yeah but macron is
young too
he's in the 30s the guy in italy is like
31
like there are people like the rest of
the world has like people
like it it's a star wars fan and menace
and like the princess
princess is like 13 14 and she's like
the dem
that's what like the rest of the world
looks like compared to our leaders where
you're like
and he's millennials blame millennials
well i blame uh
boomers well millennials what are they
doing
i mean they're trying to make it i think
most people yeah i guess but like how
many millennials are actually running
for office you're they're doing it
they are but they get they i'll tell you
what millennials are doing they're
complaining on the internet
these these these you know guys putting
up like cameras in their bedrooms and
then doing these youtube shows where
they bring people in all they do is talk
talk talk talk probably wear a beanie 24
7.
not running for office not leading the
charge it just won't go off
it's hard i could make fun of the other
millennials but the the thing is that
when you have institutional power i know
so many politicians who they doubt
they never want to leave i mean joe
biden was in office for a
hundred thousand years he's been office
within like 25 of the history of the
country
and he never once leave there was
probably other people incentive to
delaware but they were never going to be
ousted by they're not going to oust joe
biden
they're never going to oust mitch
mcconnell mitch mcconnell is like a
turtle i mean he literally is like 300
years old
dianne feinstein is in her mid-90s and
she is just
there forever and it's just
there are sure there's young people in
california who want to run for office
rokana could be that position but yeah
but
they never they never get the
opportunity because people just stay
forever
and i'm not supportive of term limits so
it's i'm not endorsing that but
i mean you never want to let that stage
go
something did weird did happen because i
pulled up this thing from uh pew about
the generational gap in politics
2018 was interesting we're seeing a lot
more younger people there's uh what was
it
madison hawthorne aoc obviously you're
getting a lot more younger people who
are coming in
but there really was a period where
millennials
and i'm not going to blame gen z they're
not quite at that point yet but
millennials are entering their for
getting close to their 40's yeah we only
have a handful
and who's and who's doing anything
substantive in politics and culture
leading the church so as much as i can
make fun of
myself like why i think what we're doing
is important we're engaging in civics
we're engaging in politics
we're communicating with other
millennials and talk about these issues
obviously the people who are watching
are engaged but there is a large large
portion of millennials who are just
abstaining from politics well i mean but
look at them i mean and i'm not giving
excuses to people out but we did
get we did get it rough we came into age
during the oa crisis we did and then we
got the
and then we got the cro i mean coveted
into our thirty
there was a lot of speed bumps that we
hit on the way to adulthood
that's why i was gonna say maybe i blame
boomers a bit boomers definitely deserve
a lot of blame for a lot of things they
held onto power for too long
they misguided it they had these large
notions they didn't have the sense of
duty the way that
or they didn't expand the sense of duty
that that
their parents didn't think weren't they
hippies yeah they're the hippie
generation
some of them only called their own
percentage though but but could you
imagine this generation geriatric
boomers as i'm a german
geriatric millennial i've been told
could you imagine these these you know
boomers who are like hippies who are
partying and you know
like live free free love and then as
soon as they got older they were like
mine my stuff yeah and listen to dr
fauci
right that's i mean that is literally
who they became is everything they have
heard that
the hippie movement really got derailed
by the drugs like they just did too many
and they just it's fun as it was but
they people that have looked back were
like if we hadn't done all the drugs we
would have been able to have a political
movement for real
well i'm sure i'm sure that when i mean
they're the best when you go around the
pentagon and try to elevate it with your
levitated with your brain eventually is
that what they did yeah yes that was
famous they went they were on they're
trying to levitate the pentagon
who was that was david leary right it
didn't work that didn't surprisingly
it wasn't like that ball it keeps
levitating about it didn't happen so i
mean well hold on hold on but was it
like were they doing like light as a
feather stiff as a board
where you get like seven million i don't
think they can hold underneath the pen
but they but no this is a famous you
know this yeah i think david leary who
was like trying to levitate the pentagon
with their brain i believe it was david
leary but yeah
i mean they timothy tim timothy leary
timmy lear not david david
who's like one of the pioneers of lsd
yeah yeah it's timothy leary i think he
tried to levitate
we got it from smithsonian mag 50 years
ago a rag tag group of acid dropping
activists tried to levitate the pentagon
yes
imagine what you must have done wrong to
create a
generation where people all show up like
let's levitate the
building man and they're like nothing's
happening dude
did you do more acid let me try and you
know one guy was like wow it worked
like i mean one guy was like that
totally worth it
totally worth it
and we were levitating with it yeah yes
but i mean and that's the generation
that's out there and
hung on to institutional power and
wealth and they have way too much of it
and they
and in a lot of ways they sold out a lot
of things that
gave them that ability to to mask that
wealth because it made them wealthier i
mean like things like normalizing trade
relations with china
and you know stopping a lot of a lot of
other things as well
but yeah that's that's the boom the
bonuses have a lot of and there's a
great book by my co-podca i have a
podcast
with american conservative magazine
called right now my co-author mike
michael
helen andrews wrote a book called
boomers it's a great book
so is it i'm going to go ahead and say
we can keep reducing the problem you
know trying to figure out where it's
rooted you can say
well the boomers who who who had the
boomers the greatest generation
yeah the silent generation silent
generation no silent was gen xers
no silent is like 1916.
no no it's silent boomers but
the greatest generation was they came
back from world war ii you had a bunch
of babies yeah yeah
yeah yes yes yes so what did the
greatest generation do
wrong that created a bunch of they made
the suburbs and that's that's where
everything went wrong
no i just think that i think that you
know if you grew up in the depression
and you grew up and you went to world
war ii which was a lot of that
generation growing through
really hard times worse than millennials
had it you kind of want
normalcy and you want and you probably
are
a little quieter in your beliefs and and
that was and that you don't sit there
and stimulate
you know overstimulate telling you know
a lot of things and also not all boomers
a lot of boomers went to vietnam and
they phoned a horrible war they should
have been a part of and like
some boomers did sacrifice a lot but the
overall
like me focus on me going to the suburbs
i need to have a bigger plot alone i
need to have
you know i think that definitely
affected a lot of people's psyche as a
part of like this is about me
because those boomers later on went on
to go because if they were born in the
40s
they came of age voting for the you know
the me generation with reagan their kids
absorbed it big time which was the
exercise probably our better generation
we have alive today as the xers
and i say that as a millennial but yes
yeah yeah
because they were the most ignored the
actors never got attention bernie they
were punk man
i think the greatest generation came
back from all this hardship overseas
and they were like i'm going to do
everything in my power to make sure that
my kids have
everything they want i want to live the
american dream i will raise them that
way i never wan i want them to go to
college you know i don't want them
that might be but they also inherited
their their they also inherited the
greatest generation
everything they built but also if you
grow up
in depression and war in really terrible
situations
you of course you want normalcy for your
account of course like that is your
natural instinct they built it on the
back of war spoils basically the u.s was
the only country that didn't get
leveled during world war ii our soil
didn't get invaded so we had massive
wealth
and they and they created a system on
top of that that could only subsist
with that level of weapon but if you
look at the drop-off
it it does decrease starting in the 70s
but when they normalize trade relations
with china and when they go into nafta
you see it plummet and they catapult
them off the gold standard
purely for that reason no nixon took us
with a gold center because he couldn't
afford lbj's
spending deals and he couldn't also he
couldn't also pay for that anymore he
couldn't he couldn't repeal it
and he needed to get off the gold
standard i mean i don't bla i don't i
don't think that was a great choice but
i don't blame nixon for that because he
couldn't he couldn't get rid of the the
great society
and lbj is one of the worst presidents
of all time millennials
aren't leading and i don't know if it's
an excuse to say well we had two
you know major economic crises i mean
people have their hardship
that what the boomers also had vietnam
didn't they yeah they had vietnam but
they also had
a massive amount of stability and i
think that i mean if you look at the
inequality between generations it's it's
huge right now
um and i definitely yeah boomers hold it
boomers hold
huge sums of wealth and it's not even
close to where millennials will ever be
this is crazy i saw uh forty percent of
millennials have not had their first
child yet and they're going to the
future and
there was some data from a few years ago
that said uh people who are 29 are have
a net negative
a negative net worth of about a thousand
dollars and only at 30 do they go
positive
but i saw a meme i don't know if this is
true it was just a meme and they said
mark zuckerberg
accounts for two percent of all
millennial wealth oh my god
would that would not surprise i mean
that would be shocking number but it
wouldn't surprise me the other day two
percent
that's that's a lot i mean it sounds
small but consider how many millennials
there are
one guy one guy is two percent well and
and add that to all of
all the people came on what came out of
the tech boom who like created like i
don't know how much time for myspace is
worth but like
all those 500 okay but still if you add
all those people together who made
who made something became a billionaire
or 100 million or whatever and
accumulated together i'm sure they
they make up like a dozen people
probably make about significant half
yeah and that's that is that is
genuinely a
wild one look i i can i can look at the
older generation and blame them for not
instilling proper values
in millennials but when when you get
people who
think the path towards making money is
accruing hundreds of thousand dollars in
in school debt
but you're sold on that from like from a
kid you're saying that's why you're
gonna go
to college and but at a certain point
there's gotta be responsibility for the
individuals
so that's why i look at this like our
society sold a lie
to millennials and screwed them over so
i'm in favor of some kind of debt relief
that isn't
just paying off everyone's debt so i i
think maybe like terminating interest
rates
pay down the principal no more interest
rates accrue you can still defer
because how do you have a generation how
do you have a country
when an entire generation owns nothing
except for like mark zuckerberg
and they're saddled with a debt that
just keeps going up well more
importantly colleges should have to
co-sign their loans
yeah colleges should not call one we
should seize the endowments there's no
question
thank you harvard has 120 billion by
themselves tax-free
that they do nothing besides you know
institute the worst ideas in the society
but colleges should have to co-sign your
loan if they're gonna make you pay 200
grand for you know a degree in basket
weaving
they should co-sign that they should not
sit there and say oh you know yeah
best of luck to you on your path of i
don't know becoming a brand who sells
best
i don't know anything but they should
have to co-sign your own because if they
did they would not give out
the nonsense degrees they do they would
not have the cost be as high as they do
um and they would perform something i
mean colleges get away with a lot
and also they're the it's they're so
hypocritical because it's like the home
of the biggest leftists the biggest
bleeding heart progressives
and every way the college administration
works
is like them is the most money grabbing
kind of organization
in the entire world it is like it is
like
a wolf of wall street would not be as
deceptive as college institutions are
and i say this is a college dropout so i
mean i'm not someone i didn't spend a
lot of time in academia but you see the
way it works
it is they they preach one thing and
they operate a completely different way
scam factories it is total scam
it's great to see colleges have an
incentive to get jobs for the students
that was the best that was the best
thing happened because of cove it was
some people dropped out of college and
they're like i'm not going to go for a
year and figure something out
i mean i really hope some people figure
something out besides going to college
because i mean
i also didn't go and i know i'm a unique
how i make money whatever
but there has to be a path for people
outside going to university i mean
they're just there has to be
maybe we needed some kind of you know
like great
restart or or reset but that's some sort
of reset
yeah a great one i was just like
it took me a second no but this is like
this is like where
this is where i talked to a congressman
from the midwest the other day about
this
you know they're always about
repatriating stuff from china now and
bringing back our health care and our
military stuff and our production value
actually building factories whatever
if you left that up to market forces
alone they would go to arizona texas
california for the shipping and the
newest and best
uh uh rail and all the rest roads
everything internet
um real infrastructure not like the bs
infrastructure that biden was
selling else on like you know child care
if you really want to revive the places
who've been devastated
for up to 30 40 50 years of bad trade
agreements and
chinese manipulation all the rest of it
you need government power to sit there
and say okay
not only is this aspirin factory going
to come back to the united states
it's going to go to detroit and we're
going to figure out a way to make it
incentivize you to go to detroit
it could be a tax thing it could be what
do you need you need better better wi-fi
you need five whatever you need
what do you need we're going to make you
go to akron ohio
or go to altoona pennsylvania or go to
erie pennsylvania these places that have
been
just there they are on the precipice of
annihilation as
a people go you know and that has a
whole psyche with where you have
you know in america in our lifetime the
life expectancy was declining
in broad sections of the country and
this is in my book if you are born
they're not listening hallelujah the
national poppies revolution um but if
you were born in
kentucky or west virginia as a white
person or the mississippi
delta as a black person or in the native
american reservations as a native
american person in south dakota
you're going to die 20 years before
someone is born in the suburbs of denver
colorado
that is just the huge discrepancy of
life expectancy
south dakota has the parts of dakota
have the lowest life expectancy
in the western hemisphere i i hear you
and i i understand that we probably do
have the resources to solve a lot of
these problems
but who's going to blow up the kids
overseas if you take the money away from
international excursions and you know
but no but it's not even i'm i'm on
board with you
there 110 percent but you and i mean the
army is a jobs program in many aspects
of it but at the same time if you're
going to sit there and have
if covid was going to sit there on
deficit or economy and we're going to
rebrand it and not every job being an
amazon job
and you want to actually improve the
lives of working-class people who have
been
from from urban areas to rural to
ex-urban who have been
devastated by our modern economy and and
by the modern system
you need government involvement you
can't leave up to the free market alone
and that's what the right is completely
missing in this entire moment i know
that's
we're on a tour well you see that with
attack the mish mish management of the
tech
you know oh they don't even know what
tech is i mean literally it's a private
company so it can do it you can do
whatever i want you know
you know absolutely i it's it's it's
like seeing like a guy screw your wife
and say oh it's free will she wanted to
do it too like it's
they're saying that yes exactly like
yeah you know it's free well so she
you shouldn't be upset because it's it's
what she wanted it is
literally nuts what they're sitting
there and doing and they're they're
they're condoning
losing because it's very profitable in
the in the government sector to lose
it's very profitable you sell a lot more
books as the minority party
and do a lot more speakings than you do
how come you don't support uh
term limits we have them in new york
and they don't really work chiefs of
staff run for the last position
for the person passing you and then they
become inherently the chief of staff it
doesn't actually create massive change
in bureaucracy oh so you see people in
the administration take the old role
yeah it happens all the time like it
literally it's just cycling the same
nonsense you don't really see like
i mean we do have some things in new
york we have a campaign finance laws
where we
do matching funds or you do have some
people run for office that's
handled to an extent but they do try to
do a good job so i
i do have one idea that i think you know
i know a lot of people talk about
term limits and we go back and forth on
whether to work or not um
we could just hear me out take a a giant
uh spaceship like the one that elon musk
has created
put all of the politicians on it and
send it to mars
and then just go about our business i
was on a bachelor party trip and why
this one guy randy paul can stay though
and he was a big stoner he was like guys
we just stopped paying taxes we won't
have a government anymore we want to
play paintball and he was shot the first
10 seconds of every game
he goes bro that happens i'm ko like
don't even bother calling me anymore
yeah i don't know it's a very hard thing
to sit there and do but there are very
practical things the government could be
i was
i was on my way here and we're on a road
with
stretches of acres of land on both sides
of us and there's traffic and it's two
lanes and like right
this is one thing if there's the
government could build an extra lane
like i'd be okay with it no one would
sit there and protest
one extra lane i don't there's plenty of
land i get if you're like there's no
place to build but there is or tunnels
i mean you want to build let's create a
jobs program united states
just multi-layer roads like you know
chicago's got upper and lower wacker
something i shouldn't be able to sit
cool by the way i shouldn't just sit in
mass amounts of traffic
and this is the problem is that
people would be okay with the
government's nonsense if they did the
bare minimum
the quality of life thing if i wasn't in
the nation's capital
walking my dog on a block with nine
homeless people who are talking
themselves
if we could just solve the basics people
excuse a lot and i i really do feel like
our government at this point is like you
know it started out with someone
creating you know christmas lights and
they're and they're rolling them up real
perfectly
and then each time they hand off the
roll of christmas lights they get a
little more tangled
and now this is like where we're at it's
like you know five six generations seven
generations
and we're just holding this big bundle
thing and we're like we don't even know
what connects to what or like where that
goes
and everyone's arguing about how to
untangle it but no one can figure out
what's going on it gets to the point
where once you receive
a tangled ball you just assume that it's
tangled by nature you don't even get
untangled yes and it's also right and
that's the way it's always been and it's
also the people who want to untangle it
the most
are like well what does what does
procedure say
and what what should we do what's in the
what's in what's in the constitution
what we can do not oh what power can we
just sit there and use boldly to sit
there and
and no we have to ask bureaucracy to to
lower themselves and that's why local
governments are more responsive because
they're
they are smaller but because they are
they it's literally like
what service can you provide immediately
not like these long
you know alienated beliefs that no one
is i think we've just got uh you know
this jumbled up system of a bunch of
criss-crossing weird laws and rules and
regulations that are confusing everybody
but that's what but what happened and i
wrote this in the book by the way and i
talk about this constantly in my in my
newsletter
the national populist newsletter is that
what happened in all these other
countries was finally it was enough
and they voted for these outside parties
that are that are very radical in their
beliefs and how they do it
now we have a first-past-the-post system
which is like you have to get the
majority in your individual district so
it's a little different it's a little
harder to have that
but we're seeing changes within the
two-party structure that are saying
it just doesn't work for us and yeah
some of those people are the aocs of the
world and they're
like you know nuts and then some of the
people are you know real reformers who
want to do something and we may see them
coming out
who sit there and say to like you know
the libertarians of the world like oh
great you know
government can be used for something
good i don't think aussie's nuts
i think she's more what's what's the
word for
when you want to trick people into
stealing from them
you know yeah that that that's right
yeah bribery subservient who's that guy
who just deceitful
oh okay i was joking uh she just
contradicts herself and says whatever
her audience time wants to hear
he hasn't actually debated yeah like
when she was like trump is running
concentration camps
legal asylees have broken no law and the
guy is like what's his name homan what's
that guy's name
they broke section 23. he like just read
it out to her
and then when joe biden gets elected and
they reopen the homestead facility she
says
detention center you know immigration
facilities with controversial records
what a great leap from concentration
camp my problem with populism is when
you get a backlash to enact or
you know faulty systems and then you
just get some really popular person that
doesn't know what they're doing like
that's not ours like like cortez or like
you got pol pot you got hitler that's
not no but they're all popular
yeah but they weren't most of those
people you just mentioned were not
democratically elected
or like legit i mean hitler was democrat
well he has seized power but he was
like he was but mal was not
democratically elected to sit there in
his position a lot of them aren't
um yes and there are some very bad side
effects i mean
uh chavez was democratically elected
yeah there are but there are also people
who are democratically elected
like you know orbit in in hungary people
aren't being marched into concentration
camps he's not i mean as horrible as
people say it isn't in hungary
what did he do he said to women oh if
you want to stay home and have kids i'll
give you a social security check
and uh like i mean yes and it started
yeah
science scientifically changed but like
yeah there are people who do radically
terrible things
but it's also like owning a gun yeah
some people are nuts and they shouldn't
be holding
a firearm and some people are genuine
and can actually do something with the
power you go
look you know we're at this point where
you've got the democratic party wholly
embracing black lives matter and
the left wholly embracing black lives
matter and the symbol that they fly on
their flags
is literally the symbol of communism it
is the red salute
yeah as a fact and they'll tell you it
doesn't mean that it means something
else i'm like
shut up if somebody marches around doing
the roman salute i'll call that guy a
nazi
you're not gonna play any stupid games
with me they're holding up the red
salute
that's what they do they put it on their
flags a guy tattooed on his neck and
then went and shot a trump supporter
we are looking at extremists they don't
care
they're not going to argue with you you
this is the problem conservatives have
is they think they're arguing with
someone who's interested yeah they think
they're going and sitting down with the
guy who's literally got
the red salute tattooed on his neck and
they're like but hear me out here's why
i think this policy is wrong and they're
like i'm i'm interested i'm actually
arguing in good faith
have you ever read the federalist papers
no that is exactly i tell us all the
time conservatives you're playing a game
that there's
that they're not following the rules
like you're literally playing chess and
there's no way to move any pieces we
want that's right
i don't see populism functioning in the
democratic party
in that bernie sanders i thought was for
sure going to be a nominated and elected
in 2016 and then that happened and then
20 2020 again
but because of super delegates this
ridiculous like it's a totalitarian
decision-making process in the beginning
yeah when the when the bird landed on
his podium i was like oh gandhian
it was just insanity yeah yeah no it's
it's uh that's where that came from that
bird i just didn't know that the bird
landed on his podium yeah i remember but
i was talking about i didn't make sense
like dude it's like like levitating the
pentagon like i'm seeing things right
how amazing was it though
how did you feel ian after uh bernie was
you know fighting the system and the
bird landed
and then he got up on the stage and was
like i'm going to now get on my knees
and lick the feet of hillary clinton i
cried but i was so sad i couldn't cry
it was in my it was in my gut but that
just i laughed that just shows like
there's like no honest leftist left
like back in the day there would have
been an honest lap just like no screw
you and
the dumb ones are honest they're just
they don't understand they don't have
power though yeah but like
that aoc is endorsing biden going along
with it i mean
if you're this big revolutionary you
don't do that like this
this this you know this this is the big
problem there was this thing posted on
twitter by
shuon had about she posted this thing
where it was like the more i read the
more i scroll and it was like the guy
turning into style or whatever and it
was a github thing where it's like let
me show you in inches the wealth of jeff
bezos or whatever
and it said like in one day jeff bezos
made 13 billion dollars and it's like
no he didn't anyway and then it's like
here's how much you need to
uh home all homeless veterans and i'm
like money doesn't put homeless veterans
in homes
these are children all right this is
what what bothers me is like i'm not
going to have a debate with someone
who's like
there's like homeless people will like
why don't we just put them in a house
like that's so dumb like
you could just you put them in the house
it's like do you know why people are
homeless
mental illness and then drug abuse
number two number one and not only and
that is working poor as well
and there's choice so i've worked i
worked for a network of homeless
shelters
the biggest problem was you could
literally walk up to a guy who was of
sound mind and body
who was just poor and say to him we have
a house
legit house we can put you at it we get
some clean clothes he's like no
really yup why because they don't want
to leave they like
they've met so it's not every single
person a lot of people just assume
homelessness is always this
this bad position that people have
unfortunately found themselves in
not realizing that some people choose to
do this it's like shawshank redemption
where they like being in prison yeah i
suppose but
i won't even feel like being in prison
some of these people are like i wake up
outside with fresh air i can walk
wherever i want
i can sleep wherever i want i have
nothing to worry about i can do what i
want
and so they end up sleeping and dragging
around crap and they smell bad
and it just creates homeless camps and
they like doing it well austin just
banned their homeless camps
so one of the things you deal with is
that people refusing
to go to the shelter saying i won't do
it i don't want to do it i'm going to
stay here
so then you get northern california
actually saying they'll seize the assets
of people who are homeless if they
refuse to like you know engage in
whatever
you have some people who are mentally
unwell yeah but think about this
let's say you just said you know what
don't care what you think don't care
what your abilities are we're gonna take
you we're gonna put you in a house
pipe bursts now you've got someone who's
mentally unwell sitting in a room
rocking back and forth as they're being
sprayed with water
and the floors are soaking up and who's
there to help them
who maintains the property these people
are children who don't understand
there is a massive economic system at
play that makes your
houses function that's why when you get
this black lives matter woman who's like
i'm gonna buy five houses
it's not just about the five houses it's
about the groundskeeper
it's about the building manager it's
about somebody's gotta be managing all
the taxes on this someone's gonna be
managing
the the day-to-day expenses the mail
that's showing up
there i'm sure she has a staff that's
dealing with this to maintain all of
these houses
or as she said her family is living in
them it's not just the house just sits
there and is full of money
and so what happens is you get people on
twitter with hundreds of thousands of
followers
posting something they absolutely do not
understand
by it's it's it's unfortunately it's
midway well that's why zoomers and
millennials get their education from
social media they're almost as bad as
boomers are with their
with facebook posts but now on instagram
and twitter where it's just like a
literally a picture that's supposed to
explain a large
system and that's why you get a lot of
the beliefs on black lives matter to go
back to where we
first a lot of it's like oh well black
people are 13
of the population but they're you know
this percentage of the well what
percentage of crime do they commit what
percentage
like there's a lot more than what you're
giving and what your but your education
comes from memes
that's a problem jeff bezos makes about
a million dollars a year
in benefits and his salary is eighty
three thousand dollars
he has stock he can't just sell the
stock he has contractual agreements and
obligations and they say like when
certain price points are reached he's
allowed to sell out certain amount of
the stock
so they say he made 13 billion dollars
in one day no the value of amazon as a
company went up 13 billion
but there is no circumstance in which
jeff bezos
could say i'm going to liquidate all of
my stock into cash right now for 185
billion dollars
it's not possible there's no
circumstance in which you could probably
even pull out 10 billion dollars
it is in weird increments it's small
it's imaginary
the funniest thing is how people who
don't
understand economics talk about
economics when they say things like i
remember when shane smith
of vice was a billionaire and i'm like
oh is he a billionaire why
because he sold a percentage of vice for
you know several 300 million dollars so
his
hypothetical holdings of that company
multiplied by
the investment percentage creates a net
worth of billions of dollars
congratulations that
and five bucks will get you cup of
coffee at starbucks people don't
understand what wealth really means
they think that bezos has all this money
can just throw around they think
zuckerberg has
money they're rich don't get me wrong
right they own like you know bezos has a
mega yacht that costs like half a
million dollars
because he is a billionaire but when
they come to you and they say like
we should tax 185 billion dollars of
bezos it's like he doesn't have that
but we should tax it anyway how would he
pay the taxes on that with a wealth tax
if you if you're charging him with one
percent he's got to pay
1.8 billion dollars he doesn't have that
in liquid assets then he should sell his
stock
he's not legally allowed to well we
should force it we should take it from
him okay so you're saying you want to
liquidate amazon
and lay off tons of people and shut the
company down because you don't like that
this guy's rich
and then have no money and no resources
to help anybody it makes literally no
sense you want to reform the system fine
do your research
stop wasting my time because you're not
arguing anything but then you have to
deal with the fact that these people
like bernie sanders are in politics
and are making policy and then
millennials are just sitting here
complaining
and they vote and they vote this big
problem who are the zoomers
zoomers are generation z i think born
after 1997.
they're like in their 20s now it's like
the kids oh okay
yeah it's like the kids who are like
generations they're either in cells or
they're like
they've got no hair is it because they
used zoom a lot
no z i don't know zoomers this is really
boomers
zoomer so generally this is really crazy
uh zoomers are in cells
yeah no joke um i'm not trying to be
disparaging they don't have sex a lot
yeah there was a story from the
washington post showing that like more
than a third
up to like the age of 29 were virgins so
that doesn't include something i do
know a significant amount of 20 year old
men who are virgins like a sing
like i knew none when i was like a 23
year old or i knew like a handful who
were like were trying to get laid but
just couldn't
like 50 in bangkok couldn't help them
but now
i know a significant who are just
choosing not to have sex no it's not
even a choice
it's like uh they have no ambition they
have no ambition i went through
a celibacy phase and it was kind of my
choice but like three weeks long
yeah yeah it was like five years it was
a lot of like hoping that i would meet
someone and i would spend like
swipe right i hope that this works out
but that's not how you find someone no
they don't make it happen there's the
moment when you find it they're not
trying like they're
not trying to meet somebody like they
don't know it i i think they don't know
how
i don't know i don't know but like i'm
like let me help you i'm
one one of my friends i won't say his
name but he uh great guy
but he was like i'll make a dating app
and they're like name an interesting
thing about you and he wrote i love
virtue i'm like
are you joking me no one's going to
swipe right i'm like tell you do a great
impression of like apu on the simpsons
i don't know something like don't do
like this you know it's funny have you
have you ever watched it's always sunny
philadelphia yes
when he puts on his dating profile like
he's like what do you what's your
favorite food like milk steak yes
but here's the funny thing in the show
it's like what what's milk steak
if you actually made a profile and said
you loved milk steak you'd get women
being like i love it's always sunny like
yeah something is something yes
something nonsensical you gotta put that
don't put like your actual heart and
emotion like this like you'll get
destroyed in life it's like twitter like
you know you be
it's a vultures twit tinder and all
these apps are
really really awesome i never had a
dating app and i wish like i didn't so i
never experienced like what that's like
but and it must be horrible to try to
make like general conversation but if
you can't make conversation in real life
right on everybody how the hell can you
make conversation on just an app or
i don't know some people are really good
at it and some people you know well i
don't know what the exact reason for it
but washington post
ran the story where they showed that
this is a couple years ago men
29 and under were substantially more
likely to be virgins
like 33 or or more percent and i
i was we talked about this quite a bit i
think it's dating apps because
it opens up the dating pool for younger
women to older men that didn't used to
exist right a 35 year old guy
had very little access to 22 year old
women he'd have to go and lurk around
colleges was kind of weird
now it's just on the app boom there boom
yeah could it also be a porn's big deal
but
also be like like you have a fear of
being accused of
being for sure yeah i'm sure that it's
part and like zoloft like different
drugs that diminish sex drive but porn
there's a huge number of
like 20 year olds who have uh like
dysfunction down there they can't get it
up or whatever
like yeah because the porn has a problem
yeah there's a lot of porn yeah
violent porn is just well on the psyche
to uh before we go too deep let's go to
super chats yes
if you haven't already smash that like
button get your super chats in now we're
gonna start reading your questions and
comments and go to timcast.com become a
member because we have
an exclusive members-only segment this
is remember only segments i already know
we're gonna talk about it's gonna be
crazy it's gonna talk about the craziest
religion conspiracy aliens all coming
together because obama's talking about
aliens we're going to talk about this
so go to tipgus.com sign up if you want
to see that episode and again smash that
like button and share this show with
your friends
we got manian lee says can you get brett
weinstein on to discuss the covet lab
leak hypothesis
i would absolutely love to it's just
really difficult to get people from far
away but uh
brett you are always welcome and we will
reach out
starscream says fyi colonial network is
being reported as down again per the
daily mail yes numerous outlets reported
this earlier today
that a communications network for the
colonial pipeline was down
so uh whatever gas panic here comes
again
make 1984 fiction again says it is
tuesday may 18th in massachusetts is
still secretly leading
number one totalitarian authoritarian
regime in the marxist state of america
as that would be the case oh there's a
great ryan c made a little mouse
chasing a five dollar bill and a flower
what a nice little
piece of art i love it christian
jim gocheon says i nearly jumped up and
cheered during my shift today when the
d.a
spat in the face of blm saying at a
press conference that the andrew brown
killing was justified based on brown's
own actions
that's right yeah all right
loon ching says hi tim and crew
have you heard of the new stoplan token
grew 20 times in a mere two days love
your work from singapore
there are a lot of tokens like dave
portnoy i guess he called did he call
safe moon a ponzi scheme or something
it was hilarious because he's like i
don't know but some dude this is funny
uh uh hotep jesus retweeted some guy i
don't know who it was but he called dave
portnoy lettuce hands
why because you know like paper hands
yeah because apparently he like he sold
his crypto or something and he's like
keeps losing whenever he like does these
bets
that's funny i think the important way
is cool guy but he's a cool guy too yeah
donny jr says telcoin ceo assisted
nebraska with bill
lb649 which is a statewide framework for
cryptocurrency and digital asset banks
passed to final debates today cool stuff
crypto is the revolution man we're i
think we're at that that major turning
point
how do you know bad crypto from good
crypto read the white paper
most of it's bad crypto it's like the
ethos of the paper yeah and what the
crypto actually does
and you got to look at the company look
at the people involved because i don't
know
legitimate developers anything about cr
i don't know anyway crypto and i just
certain ones are like computer programs
called smart contracts which can
facilitate like if i send you money and
then you need to
everyone says bitcoin's the only good
one or the best experience it's the
safest
there's a state everything goes up and
down based on bitcoin in many ways
ethereum is good and so i have
four right now i have bitcoin ethereum
uh dogecoin and cardone you got into
dogecoin
for fun okay i thought it was it doesn't
really do anything technically right
right but elon elon's trying to pump it
i think he's scamming people yeah in my
opinion so you really got to read the
white papers
um and you can see ahead of time like
this crypto will facilitate transactions
between the ethereum blockchain and the
bitcoin blockchain and so
you'll see it has a value that it's
coded to have a value some are just like
we will make
a hundred million of these tokens and
then so i don't do anything so i i could
probably
just snap my fingers and create what's
called a token which would exist on the
ethereum blockchain
and i could call it something like
beanie coin and i could make a million
of them and then be like they're for
sale and probably make money
yeah like just like that one of my
female comic one of my female comic
friends said
you know when women are never going to
like close the gap between men on income
because they
men just make their own money now like
constantly so like
every time we think we're getting close
like no they're going to make their own
coin
so i think uh so i'm not giving anyone
financial advice you buy whatever you
want
bitcoin's the obvious it's the big dog
it's first in best dressed
ethereum is the best technology in my
opinion for now because software apps
are being developed using it
so for instance mines.com so i do have
another i have mines tokens because i'm
on mines
and then uh dogecoin is a joke and it's
funny and i get what cardano was saying
to me it kind of feels like once they
get up to the point where ethereum's at
it's going to explode in value as well
so it's a good investment
i'm not giving you advice on what to buy
no i don't know any i mean i
i'm not a technology person i don't know
how wind happens so i'm not like i'm way
behind
the thing but i just want to get more
interested i'm you know
yeah it's going to help stabilize the
economy yeah okay
good to know on a state by state level
all right lauren holliday says tim this
is my first super chat
we are christians do you do you never
dialogue with non-catholics
we would love to talk to you all god
bless you i mean i think it's actually
funny because most of the religious
people
are catholic yeah yeah yeah i didn't
know that but yeah i guess so
i'm catholic yeah i look even though i
look like a jew are you devout
catholic what does that mean you know do
you study it heavily and like fall no
because i'm
i'm a cradle catholic so i don't have to
study we're just kind of born with it
like we have like you know
like christians read the bible catholics
get a man to give you a book report at
the end of every week and that's what
you sit there and live with and that's
that
so we don't i'm that kind of no but i go
to church on sunday so if that's devout
then that's what i do
all right joseph allen says hey tim i
just got my to the moon shirt today i
love it
my girlfriend said the light blue color
brings out my eyes
that's right if you go to timcast.com
and go to the store we have a special
shirt it's to the moon it's a sheba
in a suit holding cash with coins
exploding it's like a dogecoin joke
your girlfriend will think you're
beautiful all right comic nut
says i just said the cops called on me
last weekend for a noise complaint
and my neighbors know i'm strapped and i
let them pat me down and everything the
worst that happened was they told me to
sober up
oh nice you just keep your hands up you
know that guy there like there's
exceptions right the guy who was playing
simon says
yeah when the cop was like put your
hands up put your hands down but if you
move your hands and the guy's crying
i just landed if that were me i just lay
down there and i just did not move
i would advise him never to yell out
don't shoot don't tase me remember that
don't tase me bro
because when it comes to your duke's
friend don't tase me tase me tease me
that word like don't don't give double
negatives to to people in general
especially
yeah yeah yeah the other guy's friends
with luke right no that's awesome he's
like
what does he do now uh he writes oh i
think he's like a libertarian writer
don't tase me bro.com
yeah yes hopefully it takes me time to
say
bro daniel herron says that fouchy
impression is getting damn good
well if i actually tried to do
impressions maybe i'd be good at him you
would
you should dress sorry says hey tim how
is the hyperinflation in america going
to affect the rest of the world
from us there was a a tweet i saw out of
nigeria that inflation there is like 20
or something i don't know if that's true
i just saw some people tweeting about it
it will absolutely have a massive and
worse impact on everybody else
so basically what inflation does for
america is it allows us to devalue our
debt
this inflation stuff is really good if
you're holding massive amounts of debt
because you can take your liquid you so
so right now let's say you're rich
and you got a you know let's say you're
not rich let's say you got a mortgage
it's like 300 000 mortgage or whatever
you live in a nice suburb
and so you have maybe a few thousand
dollars
in cash you can put that into a crypto
which is gonna start going up like crazy
and you're gonna gain 10 percent and
then paying the interest on the house
you're gonna you're gonna make more
money on your investment than you would
but more importantly
when inflation hits the value of the
dollar goes down that means
the amount you owe in labor goes down as
well so rich people love it
they take up they they take their money
and they buy other currencies they buy
other assets they buy gold silver
you know cryptos whatever and then
inflation hits
their debts all devalue and then they
can swap back for even more dollars paid
all offense super easy
it's one of the tricks to owning more
stuff
all right dylan keller says wanted to
push back
just a bit on the idea the right doesn't
use crises who passed the patriot act
just playing devil's advocate no
disrespect thanks smash the gorilla and
i am a like button
yeah that's true yes they don't that was
the establishment that was that was
everyone
yeah they all were they everyone passed
everyone made the department of homeland
security but yes the right did do that
but they don't you know
bush could bush at a 90 percent approval
rating could have done anything he
wanted to do and he invaded a country
something
there's a problem with left and right
it's this like military group of like
covert military ops like
bill crystal dick cheney that like it
infiltrated the government and whatever
party it doesn't matter what party
affiliate they were they're they're
militants
i'm not a huge fan of colin powell but
when colin powell walked into the bush
white house the first day saw everyone
around him said these people are
bleeping crazies
like that was the actual quote it was
like yeah exactly he was right
it's a show says tim you killed it on
fox tonight
looking good in that beanie my friend
please shout out my show i'm starting on
this channel it's a show
one love i wish i had more time because
on fox they mentioned they're like tim
you tweeted fauci lied and people died
and i said well that tweet was in
reference to rand paul calling out the
the gain of function research and fauci
lied
because even politifact says we did
provide funding to the wuwan institute
for a gain of function
oh if i had more time i would have also
said more specifically
fauci told people not to wear masks then
it turns out we needed to wear masks
people died because of that he also said
go on cruises that's right very
important in march of 20.
he is he is directly responsible for
people doing wrong things
yeah and if you want to be the tv doctor
who comes out and says
here's what you should do well then take
responsibility when you tell people to
do
you want to know what the craziest thing
i've seen in a long time was
there's a video right now out of dallas
so this is something inappropriate but
go ahead sorry out of dallas
two guys in the army and some like
medical i don't know who he is they're
like we're gonna go give someone the
vaccine
and they walk into a 7-eleven and they
ask a guy if he wants a vaccine and they
just give it to him
now i don't know if they pre-planned
this what what they were actually trying
to prove with this but people
think because the video makes it look
like they randomly walked into a store
and found a random guy to give a vaccine
to
and i just thought to myself how insane
is it that they're
at the very least maybe maybe behind the
scenes off camera they secretly planned
it
and looked over as medical records how
insane is it
that you could be at 7-eleven and an
army guy walks in and says how would you
like to get medicated right now and
you'd go
awesome how dangerous is it to walk up
and give a medication to someone you
don't know their history
and how dangerous is it to make a movie
about a tv documentary about that making
other people think it's okay to do that
to people and like even the weirdest
thing is have you seen the covet the
covet card
there's no documentation to say that
this is like a meta there's no doctors
like the doctor there's nothing it's not
supposed to i i know but that's ins
that's literally insane because like how
do i know a dot like
how do we how do you know who gave it to
you if it's it's bizarre it is it's like
literally the most blank piece of paper
i've ever seen there's no stamp on it
there's no like
actual government issued anything
they're talking about setting up
vaccine sites outside of 7-elevens at
bars when people are drunk
and i'm like don't you need someone's
medical history before you give them a
medication
like you can't get a tattoo if you're
drunk but you can get a vaccine no it's
not even about that it's about
there are certain counter indications
for medication period yeah of course so
imagine if you walked up to a 711 the
guy was like want some valium
there's some prozac it's like no and
you're a hot dog
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah it's like oh you want you
wanted the pizza from from the counter
if you're eating food hot food of a
7-eleven do you really care about your
health that much
i think that's the first question i just
like that's bad food yeah i think it's
absolutely insane but there's this what
waiver of liability for the companies
so you can't sue them you can't see them
of course so freakish if someone came up
to me and said
i got these pills you want to take one
i'd be like no i'm not taking your
what are you doing if someone had a
needle and said you want to inject
absolutely not
i'm going to go to my doctor like every
normal person should and talk about my
health and they'll go through my chart
they have they have a record in your
computer like you know someone gets
stung by a b
and then they get all and you know
allergic and anaphylactic shock they can
be like oh well you know we should make
sure
we don't give you this vaccine because
of that reason some random guy walks
into a 7-eleven it's like here you go
and the guy's like awesome i have
allergies
period to me is nuts i mean i guess i
guess thinking about it too it's same
for a flu shot you go to walgreens and
they're like here's your flu shot it's
like
do they know anything about your history
do you i've never gotten a flu shot they
don't you know they don't ask you like
and they're like are you allergic to
eggs well at least they ask you like a
single question yeah yeah so they'll
follow up with you yeah what are you
laughing at tim
eli m says i can't send the link but if
you google black rose firearms chainsaw
bayonet a company went ahead and made
one on usa today's behalf
great show as always tim ian lives
matter hi
lm they've made a chainsaw bayonet
look it up ah is it like really small or
what does that work what's the weight
distribution that's gonna be hard like
carry after a while like that
weighs in your forearm yeah i don't know
that's gonna work yeah jonathan
nefor's says lieutenant governor
robinson is our hope here in nc
we're still wondering how we kept kami
cooper in charge but elected a rep
lieutenant governor and senator
also sheriffs in california and lincoln
county stated they won't enforce his
dumb gun laws
robinson actually got more votes than
trump did and i like him because
he grew up super poor but also was he
worked for a factory the factory got his
place by nafta
like he is a working middle class it's
because he buy that pro gun video if you
haven't watched it you should check it
out
uh that program video that became
popular and he became the nominee and
he's just he's stellar
all right dana and says biden isn't
radical he's a puppet
i predicted this when everyone but
sanders and warren dropped out and
backed him
absolutely good point if the puppeteer
is radical does that mean the puppet is
not really the puppet did you see
freedom tunes uh
new video with so you saw the photo of
biden and jill
with jimmy carter yeah they look massive
yes so
freedom tunes made a comic made a
cartoon where jimmy carter and his wife
are puppets
and they're like yeah it's really cool
yeah i've seen that picture actually
yeah cause they look like they look like
they're on their lap like as well right
right yeah
it's wild amy b says they say biden is
the most popular president ever because
he got 80 million votes
by that metric he's also the most
unpopular because 70 million
74 million voted against him that's true
pablo mendoza says i love how you
skipped gen xers lol boomers and
millennials but no gen x
well it's because the silent generation
has the gen x the boomers have the
millennials there's this jump that
happens
you know generation skip yeah so uh
generation x
they're basically just like in the
cracks they complain the least
they don't they need less attention they
made a lot of industries they were
successful they
they definitely co-opted millennials
successfully something about them
drinking a lot of pepsi in the 90s i
guess
and they watched heather's and then they
grew up and like they complained and
they listened to nirvana and then they
were like okay
we got out of our system we're good we
saw like auto come in the music industry
and didn't like it
late 40s now they're probably in their
40s 40s 40s and 50s yeah
yeah because the millennials are going
into their 40s then they are in their
40s and 50s 42 i think is the first
yeah the youngest gender yeah dana ness
says gen x aren't silent generation
we're a forgotten generation
no no the silent generation is the
generation before boomers
and they had gen xers yeah and they had
genetics they birthed gen x
yeah that's correct we're a forgotten
generation outnumbered by boomers and
millennials
yeah but you're better mexican american
conservative says
have you seen the life cycle of
democracy look it up gang and tell me
what you think
okay i will love angel says when i was
young nearly all the jobs were gone
and getting told getting told only way
to get a job was to go to university
that's right no one
to you says likes don't register unless
you press three times
wiped after commercials i'm not the only
one experiencing this mostly
conservative content the salt must flow
so yeah there was some weird thing that
happened where youtube announced that
there was a glitch with likes or
something
yeah i don't know for sure but like a
bar appeared on all the channels being
like we fixed an error having to do with
this
a lot of people were chatting about it
so if you would like to support the show
smash that like button we appreciate it
corey thomas says
i'm really curious to learn why ryan
isn't a proponent of term limits
great show and great guess as always ps
a month and a half into living in az and
it's great well i think you
uh yeah it just doesn't i mean i've seen
it in new york and it doesn't work
great a lot of times and most people get
cycle through the establishment they
just kind of elect their own people
so the same policies you just have
different faces proposing it i've just
maybe worked different other places but
in new york i i haven't seen it
work wonders or if you didn't let people
from the administration run
yeah like if you couldn't work you
couldn't have worked in the government i
mean i don't know and also by the way
the staffs generally stay the same
like the new person will come in and
bring in the same staff
who done everything it's i don't see it
as very effective
all right boris r says i grew up in the
soviet union in the 80s we had mandatory
training with assembling and shooting
ak-47 throughout high school
it's hard to get guns in russia but
everyone knows how to use one just a fun
fact
great show that's interesting all right
irish
wristwatcher says if you were in the
apocalypse and you only had to have one
gun what would be
well i have not used every single gun
but at this point it would be the
sig m400 you see crowder just sent me
one and i gotta say
i've got a couple of ars that shoot five
five six
and i've got i i got a bunch you know i
got a 50 bmg we got some 308
we've got some shotguns and i
finally get this weapon that crowder had
sent out we went to the range everybody
tried it and we were all
extremely impressed so i got a sig tread
site for it
red dot and everybody was just extremely
comfortable with it the the muzzle break
was fantastic
and so it's it's five five six you get
you know a standard uh round
magazine of course which is 30. and then
uh you're good in the apocalypse
it's a good versatility i suppose yeah
that's a good point
yeah maybe some other people would shoot
something else i guess if you're talking
about guns
and you theoretically could pick like
any gun from any point you could choose
probably like a selective fire rifle of
some sort i guess you take a rifle
though for sure
not the pistol i want the chainsaw
bayonet yes that's mine
it's cool for the zombie apocalypse yeah
exactly
we got to make an fps that has the
chainsaw bayonet yeah
that's your next t-shirt there you go
don't tread on me
with a chainsaw bayonet i love it
all right jonathan smith says the
greatest generation
they starved they fought a war came home
to kids didn't know how to be parents
every generation since doesn't know how
to raise kids asian families do that's
why their kids are successful
hey i have asian parent i have an asian
parent
there you go that explains it colin khan
it says love you ian you make the whole
podcast
thank you colleen what a bold
endorsement
we're a team colin thank you
nathan parish says hey all u.s sailor
here i recently got a promotion
and had about 11 hours of leadership
training there was very little about
leadership but a lot of talking about
diversity
and how we should strive for it can't
give opinion on this because military
i'm sure everybody thinks it's the
stupidest thing ever and it's making
everything fall apart
matthew mansfield says comparing
greatest to millennial generation from
life challenge perspective is
intellectually lazy and
it illustrates panel bias check these
kids ian
i just said that they didn't go through
the same thing that
obviously degradation i am i'm the last
year of gen x
um i did just say though no i don't
think in the last year
79 um millennials oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
i guess you're right
um yeah i feel like a millennial but i
guess i always wanted to be gen x
because all my friends the older friends
i always looked up to them
yeah you guys had a pepsi commercial
right oh man michael jackson
i
[Laughter]
you had a pepsi commercial all right mr
mcduggenstein says congress is not
supposed
to be an assisted living facility to
vote out the career politicians how
about age limits
well i would rather do term limits than
asians personally because
if i'm 80 and i want to run for
president and i'm healthy i'm down how
about
if your teeth don't fit then you
shouldn't be able to run for congress
like nancy pelosi sold her teeth
i got a better idea all right in order
to get into
any any of the chambers the the senate
or the house
there's like a long corridor with water
right
underneath and there are just logs
just place at random points and in the
water alligators
so everyone has to be able to just jump
across
and it doesn't matter how old you are if
you can't do it right i feel like chuck
grassley could do it still
like yeah like i feel like he would
wrestle an alligator just for fun but
like he like
he falls in and then you know nancy
pelosi and everyone's name they're
scared and then he climbs up the other
side with his clothes all ripped his
butt he's like
who's next
at 88 years old yeah
all right let's see youtube just jumped
into the super chats i love when they do
that
why not gordon says is there any way you
can give my gofundme a shout out my wife
is stuck in florida because of her
ex-husband
we are going to court and drowning in
legal fees the title is help my wife and
i move her to tennessee well there you
go
wow sam t says bitcoin is going to 30k
soon alt coins will moon love the show
cheers
bitcoin may go to 30. sure but it's also
going to be
happening in a couple of years which
means rewards diminish
and then the value is going to skyrocket
but a lot of people made really good
points about what's happening right now
for one you had elon musk
playing dirty games you also have tax
season
people got to pay taxes they make a
bunch of money they need money for taxes
and it's the first year you're taxed on
bitcoin right
um i don't think it's the first year
right but you are taxed on bitcoin
oh definitely okay it's just hard for
them to track you know what i was saying
this money the only commodity we don't
tax in this country right now is data
for these big tech companies they don't
tax data and it's that what they make
their money on
if you wanted to punish big tech you
would sit there and tax data
yeah like 90 percent what do you mean
90 right yeah i mean but that's the
truth or you make
your own data you have to buy data from
people and people have that that's
so cool they have to sell you your data
i mean that could be
that would be like real wealth
distribution by people by companies who
don't pay taxes that could be written
into a smart contract too like a token
would go to a person when their data was
transferred yeah
yeah i was just rallying about this
today is that that taxing data would be
the one way to
um patrick davis says everybody help
with ian's treatments i assume he is
getting help
hopefully i am i'm getting massive
amounts of help i think that's a
compliment i think they're saying
what's your job uh we're building the
fetaverse uh i don't know what that
guy's talking about
oh okay i don't want people around the
world that's like point he's making is
that
before he was critical of you and you're
doing better now so he's saying
something must be working get it yeah
you're right you're right i've been
meditating
there you go yeah perfect he's trying to
lift the pentagon right now
sadly yeah chronicles of riddick said
came to this country with two suitcases
from a socialist india
where our land was seized by the
government my first flag was issued to
me and today i have a masters in aero
engineering immigration debate should be
about legals
thoughts yeah yeah
i mean legal immigrationism is far more
important than what's going on illegally
i mean illegally it's horrendous right
now especially with the i mean with
biden just
having open borders um but no the legal
immigration argument should be
definitely happening learn the language
we got we got to help somebody out here
so so connor acevedo says i'm 22 and
i've never had a girlfriend
and i have literally no idea how to get
a girlfriend now it's such a different
scene
maybe but here's what you do first i
don't know what your situation is
start walking i i say go to skate parks
i love skate parks they're a whole lot
of fun there's a lot of people
everybody's always having a good time
and always encouraging each other or go
to the gym have a good time but it's
really really easy you guys ready for
this
you get a dog you go down to the beach
and then
you let the dog off the leash and oh no
oh yeah oh he's running over to the
oh ladies i am so sorry herman just
really loves everybody
dogs are a big thing but also listen
don't over
think things i have a lot of friends in
college especially who over
thought talking to a girl so they would
make like these raw generalizations i'm
like no
it's really like not that difficult so i
would go take them to the jersey shore
and i would walk up and say this is my
buddy so and so he's from nebraska he's
never seen the ocean before
they thought that was so cool and they
would they would want to talk to
somebody
i mean it's not always a hit or miss but
like don't over don't over
over complicate things make it real
simple and i just gotta say don't take
advice from me the dog thinks a joke
don't do it
cause i'm just imagining now like some
guy gets like a pit bull
like a a a get get a golden doodle a
gold golden doodles are like the
friendliest dogs they don't get but like
it's not that hard to talk to i don't
know where you're from where you live
maybe there aren't
like not a lot of women your age but
like it's it's not that difficult
i think it's weird it's a weird concept
to even say it's hard to talk to a girl
you look like
you should hi but no no hello fellow
human
i i listen if you in fact say that
welcome to him and go hello fellow
if you're afraid if you're afraid of
rejection if you're afraid of projection
you literally like just put it out there
enough times you will get
it maybe one out of a hundred but you
will get a yes if you just throw
yourself out there enough if you like
what you're doing that that translates
that makes you attractive to women
um yeah so whatever you like to do do it
do it and be confident about it even if
it's like playing video games or
something super nerdy
like go with it be with it yeah
especially if it's you can turn it into
some sort of get it
public facing performance because then
women will become obsessed with you
get a safari hat and binoculars and then
go to bars
and just you know walk around
that would make me laugh yeah women
women are attracted to people who are
funny so if you have
fun being funny is like having big boobs
you get all through a lot of life by
being fun it works
but i'm just imagining somebody actually
putting on a safari hat and binoculars
just because they do that doesn't mean
they're gonna be funny it might just be
like extra weird
it's like hello i uh hi
what are you doing with those binoculars
hi i'm
i'm lost and have like have like if you
get a first date have like
three interesting topics that you would
start conversation with i got it it's so
important to be able to start a
conversation and hold it yeah i got it
and ask them about themselves
learn the thriller dance and get a get
like a little bluetooth speaker and go
downtown somewhere and just by yourself
to the thriller dance and you know it'll
happen
invariably a bunch of women will come
behind you and start doing the thriller
dance with you
yeah and then you'll all be not true
don't endorse this this is not the i
know
i'm i'm kidding but i firmly believe if
you were playing thriller during the
dance people would join you oh yeah
and they do this do you know the
thriller dance no i know i don't like
the thing
yes no one under 40 knows the thriller
dance unless you are
hey hey he doesn't introduce it i said i
saw that video you're over
40 though then what do you do the chat
shot slide or something no
no don't mock arena now did that when we
were kids yes yeah
it's only five moves but like yeah but
like don't don't just start
randomly dancing like you're gonna get
arrested
go and like whoa you can dance in the
street
not like not in the streets in the
street i mean like in the city like on
the sidewalk and like
who would approach somebody who's
dancing i mean i'm from new york for too
long i would never approach someone just
dancing and
they're like dude i used to play music
in chicago on the street all the time
playing music and
randomly dancing especially there were
people who would randomly dance they'd
turn on music
and they would just do dances and people
would give them money and then people
would come over and like dance with them
and hang out
you got to dance in your mind only a
certain part of what you're counting the
rhythm
like one two three four in your lower
left corner you just pick the part of
your body that's doing the beat
one two three four and you subtly move
it so that people can't really tell
you're moving
but because you're moving you're in that
comfort flow people find that attraction
i i'd be willing to bet
i'll bet you that if you go to like if
you're in new york and you're playing
the thriller and you're doing the
thriller dance
event like while that song is playing in
one iteration someone will come up and
start dancing yes because mental illness
is rampant in new york i don't know
where this kid lives
he could be living in a corn field in
omaha i'm just sitting there and saying
if you know what
go to places where there are people your
age if you're in if you're 22 and you're
in college especially like i guess
colleges are closed now but
try your hardest there because after
college it becomes a lot harder it just
does like because you're not around
people your age as
much you have to be much more aggressive
so if you're in college go forward yeah
when you're done may i add my two cents
i don't know anything about that but i
would say that if you're working toward
a common goal it becomes a lot easier to
have something to talk about in the
first place so if you approach someone
for example in your class or someone
who's working on something with you
that's going to be good too if you
actually want someone who will work with
you in life
i think that's a good start yeah that's
just my really boring it's not a joke
it's not quite serious if you're working
toward the same goal it's really good i
agree with that
average guy 3048 says hi tim i'm a gen z
and i don't want to date any women here
in the us because i'm afraid of being
accused of something horrible
so yeah thank society so i just told you
yeah so date guys
or girl girls overseas that that's
always kind of thrilled
like immigrants who don't know illegal
aliens they can't complain they'll be
deported like i mean like
that's your option no no i'm just joking
i was a kid
no i i'm but no i don't think every
girl's like that
just it's kind of crazy because um i
wonder if the internet is doing this
you know you know the secret technique
was when i was growing up
i don't know there wasn't i just like hi
how do i get to know how
yeah well it makes anti-social people
feel your communications through
through a screen i mean doesn't mean you
wanna you know what i used to do because
i used to do fundraising for non-profits
and i'll let you in a secret for
fundraising that they'll these companies
don't tell you
men predominantly fund raise off of
women women predominantly fundraise off
of men
oh yeah so in the fundraising office you
have like
women and you'd ask them like you all
the names all dudes all dudes i'll do
the dudes
and then for me it's like all the
signups are women and so you want to
know the easiest way for me
to actually get we call it a stop like
to get someone stop and talk to you
just see someone on the street and then
i see a person walk right up reach out
my hand
yeah physical contact no no no no no i
don't touch them i reach out my hand i
know what they do
they shake my hand and i say hey nice to
meet you i'm telling you what are you
doing you go to school here
you go to you you go to columbia oh cool
yeah much my friends go here well i'm
saving the environment you want to save
the environment with me
which city do this in chicago sure i did
in chicago in california oh in new york
they'd say go after yourself like
i don't think so i don't know no no
because i would never shake my hand with
some people you wouldn't but so i
wouldn't waste my time with someone like
you
what what the the the best fundraisers
do is they
identify the way i describe it to people
when i was training was like you can you
can start to see the signs in someone if
they have like a furled brow that's a
red light you're not gonna stop resting
you know what face like
right right right yeah you're not gonna
stop then you have like yellow it's like
we can try
if you don't understand this concept
you're going to be yelling at people who
hate you
all day don't do that look for the green
light look at the people who are walking
around with a smile on their face
they're doing something specific they
got headphones in it's a waste of your
time
if they're like purposely avoiding you
don't waste your time you're doing
eye contact like yeah they make eye
contact but then you just walk up you
shake your hand hey how's it going what
are you doing and then just have fun
so i just feel like uh you know so hey
do you live you live in chicago
like oh that's cool like you go to
school here you don't go to school here
what are you doing now did you
when you walk around downtown for like
some crazy person then they'd laugh and
i'd be like no whatever man you know
here give me your credit card real quick
and they'd be like what am i i'm serious
give me your credit
no because we're saving the environment
and then they laugh it's fun maybe i'm
just you know
arrogant so it's really easy to for me
easy for me to tell people to do
your suggestion about touching physical
contact is
massively important but you're right you
can only offer
of course and it should be innocent and
don't touch people just because you want
to make a connection that's the best
thing with dating too when you first
meet someone if you make physical
contact
like usually it makes it so much easier
to interact
just here's my advice the best thing you
can do is to like go downtown
and then just identify a person you want
to meet and just start singing that meat
love song
i will do anything for love
and then there's going to immediately be
like here's my phone number he has not
offered a single good suggestion
for the 22 year old who's like writing
this down this is where you're like
anything for love
[Music]
what a year huh if you haven't already
go to timcast.com sign up because we're
going to have a
crazy and wild uh bonus segment coming
up
which should be around 11 or so you can
follow this show facebook.comcast.irl
where we post all these little clips and
you can share them
because you know we're trying to
leverage facebook to get more people to
go to our website
and you can follow us on instagram for
the same reason at uh timcast irl
and uh smash the like button share the
show do you want to shout anything out
yeah uh book they're not listening i'll
just created the national populist
revolution and my national papa's
newsletter on substack
it comes out every week and multiple
times a month and it's deep dives if you
like politics
like national populism it's definitely
the place to be because it's the only
place to be
they have it and it is confirmed i'd do
anything for love by meatloaf it's 1993.
bad out of hell too back into hell was
the album very good meatloaf yeah
meatloaf and i'm ian crossland you guys
can follow me in crossland.net and on
social media
ian crossland so thanks a lot you guys
can follow me on twitter at
sourpatchlids to help me overcome the
actual sour patch kids in follower
account that's my life goal now please
help me yeah oh that's an
account uh sour patch kids yeah yes okay
and i'm at ryan graduski yeah
on twitter twitter and instagram and all
the rest of it and you can follow me
at timcast basically everywhere we will
see you over at timcast.com thanks for
hanging out bye guys
you